after being on the air for nearly 30
years and more than 600 episodes there
aren't really many aspects of life that
haven't been touched upon by The
Simpsons as surreal as their animated
adventures may be from time to time life
imitates art you've lost count of the
times that bizarre storylines from
Springfield actually came true but here
are just a few occasions when The
Simpsons freakishly predicted the future
president Trump one of many episodes
that showed an alternate reality future
for Springfield's first family but to
the Future aired in the year 2000 and we
learned Lisa has just been elected
president of the United States during
her first cabinet meeting President
Simpson mentions a familiar name as you
know we've inherited quite a budget
crunch from president Trump we all know
how the future turned out it's worth
mentioning that this particular episode
was written during Donald Trump's failed
presidential run in the year 2000 and
the writers themselves saw the
possibility of a trump presidency as the
most ridiculous thing they could imagine
for the future which can only mean that
Lisa Simpson is up next and then
president Kang
could be worse we could be eating
Soylent which is literally named after
ground up people from a sci-fi movie
starring Charlton Heston wait
Soylent is food while not intended to
replace every meal Soylent can replace
any meal
oh what a bleak horrible future we live
in all you can eat in 1992's new kid on
the Block Homer sees a TV commercial for
an all-you-can-eat seafood restaurant
called The Frying Dutchman Homer
proceeds to eat until closing time and
gets kicked out while still hungry he
sues the restaurant for false
advertising but home around the sea
captain come to an agreement come see
bottomless Pete Nature's cruelest
mistake
come for the freak stay for the food in
2012 bill with went to a Wisconsin
restaurant called Chuck's place for its
weekly Friday night fish fry Buffet
after a few trips to the restaurant and
racking up a running tab he wanted more
but the restaurant claimed they'd run
out that's when West refused to pay we
asked for more fish and they refused to
give us any more fish the owner of
Chuck's Place claimed Wiss had eaten
more than 20 pieces of fish and was
violating the buffet's no sharing policy
he came back with a vengeance and he
wasn't done he came back two days later
with a picket sign West planned on
picketing every day but by early 2013 he
had already moved on to other protests
but really did these sound like the
actions of a man who had all he could
eat
that could have been me people are
knowingly ate gym mats over the course
of the series The Secrets of Springfield
Elementary's lunchroom cost cutting have
been explored again and again but even
lunch lady Doris has her limits what do
you want these beef hearts on the floor
in the 1995 episode the PTA disbands
even Doris objects to using shredded
newspaper and old gym mats as
ingredients shredded newspapers at much
needed roughage and essential links
besides he didn't notice the old gym
mats there's very little meat in these
gym mats in 2014 a minor but disgusting
Scandal developed when the environmental
working group released a report that
found a compound called azodar
carbonomide in around 500 processed food
products primarily breads including
Pillsbury dinner rolls your favorite
five dollar footlongs and Wonder Bread
so if you've ever wondered what put the
Wonder in Wonder Bread it's yoga mats
and yoga is totally healthy the baby
Translator by season two Homer had met
his long-lost brother herb but he leaves
Herb in financial ruin after he bets his
whole car manufacturing business on a
ridiculous car homo designs which was
called the Homer obviously
any questions left to destitute he moves
in with the Simpsons where he creates a
baby translator that turns an infant's
noise into English Maggie
[Music]
where did you go
oh there you are very amusing the
original episode aired in 1992 and by
the year 2004 Japanese Tech and toy
company Takara developed a real-life
prototype of something very similar
after previously selling a device that
analyzed the sounds of dogs barking the
Prototype analyzed the baby's sounds
facial expressions and body temperature
to alert parents if the baby was hungry
tired or needed to be changed while the
final product never emerged other
companies took the reins and produced
other devices to analyze the fleshy wear
to loud riddles at our infants ensuring
that you will always be able to
completely emotionally detach from your
helpless Offspring yay a donut-shaped
universe at the end of they saved
Elisa's brain a 1999 episode in which
Lisa and her local Mensa chapter
attempts to rule Springfield with their
Superior intellect the smartest guy in
the world makes a cameo physicist and
cosmologist Stephen Hawking and he has
some very interesting ideas your theory
of a donut-shaped universe this
intriguing Homer I may have to steal it
wow technically the shape of a donut is
a Taurus and yes as it turns out the
universe may actually be shaped like the
delicious confection four years after
Homer Simpson proposed the theory
cosmologists notice radiation patterns
in space suggesting that the Universe
was round and tube-like but empty in the
middle and that's not the only time home
has been the smartest man in Springfield
I am just parked I am smart as the Marty
I mean SM a r t the Higgs boson while
first proposed in 1964. it wasn't until
2013 that physicists discovered the
Higgs boson the field that basically
holds atoms together in other words the
discovery helps to define the very
fabric of existence and helps to
maintain How the Universe and matter
work and once again Homer was on The
Cutting Edge of Science in the 1998
episode The Wizard of Evergreen Terrace
Homer attempts to become a scientist and
inventor and is seen messing around of
some formulas on a chalkboard his
meaningless math actually gets pretty
close to the actual molecular weight of
the Higgs particle which out of an
infinite possible equations is pretty
impressive but more importantly when is
reality going to finally catch up with
the toilet chair believe me every man in
America will want to have one
Lady Gaga the halftime show of the 2017
Super Bowl made headlines with Lady Gaga
delivering a performance that was
absolutely surreal featuring high wire
stunts pyrotechnics and Theatrical
costumes having provided her own voice
for her 2012 appearance on The Simpsons
Gaga was definitely familiar with her
earlier animated performance which bore
some striking similarities to her Super
Bowl show granted gargar's Springfield
self was only a slow exaggeration on her
normally outlandish persona it's me Gaga
why is everyone looking at my purple
hair full of bloopers but this one is
pretty spot-on the Albuquerque Isotopes
the 2001 episode hungry hungry Homer is
all about Homer going on a hunger strike
to prevent the local minor league
baseball team the Springfield Isotopes
from secretly moving to Albuquerque
Moving my feet so my stomach won't hurt
in 2000 0002 the minor league Calgary
cannons announced a move to Albuquerque
and the local paper published a poll
asking readers to come up with a new
name for the team no strangers to pop
culture the name Isotopes won with 67 of
the votes while the idea of very clearly
came from The Simpsons Isotopes is
appropriate for a team moving so close
to the Laz Alamos National Laboratory at
least the power plants in New Mexico
can't possibly be as bad as in
Springfield right well in Southern New
Mexico Federal officials have confirmed
that a local nuclear plant is leaking
waste and releasing radiation into the
surrounding area nope they suck too stay
safe isotopes
renowned physicist Stephen Hawking has
died at the age of 76 but his
contributions to humanity will live on
forever including what is arguably his
life's most important work his
appearances on The Simpsons news of the
late scientist passing inspired a number
of tributes in the entertainment World
which Hawking had an outsized influence
on as a public figure the author never
restricted himself to purely academic
appearances lending his likeness or
voice to a number of high-profile pop
culture projects outside of Academia
Hawking appeared as himself on an
episode of Star Trek the Next Generation
as well as multiple episodes of The
Simpsons Futurama and the Big Bang
Theory I made a boo-boo and I gave it to
Stephen Hawking
he also lent his voice a synthesized
program to the Pink Floyd albums The
Division Bell and the Endless River
after Hawking's death a Simpsons
showrunner our Gene spoke to The
Hollywood Reporter about the experience
of arranging the professor's hilarious
first appearance on the series season 10
episode they saved Lisa's brain if you
are looking for trouble you found it
Gene explained what we would do is send
in the script and then he would record
it through his machine so it was his
voice his special audio program he did
come to the studio when he was in
America but he didn't ever go to record
over the course of his three appearances
on the show Hawking was willing to go
along with just about everything the
writers wanted him to say except one
thing in his first episode that rubbed
him the wrong way Jean said he did say
at one point that he did not want to be
drunk on screen that was the only note
we got from him he didn't mind having a
beer with Homer at Moe's but not more
this intriguing Homer I I may have to
steal it Hawking's first appearance in
which Homer Simpson famously mistook him
for Hustler magnate Larry Flint came
about thanks to a personal connection
Hawking's daughter Lucy knew one of the
show's writers who wanted to pen an
episode involving
himself
aside from the drinking scene Hawking
had no problems with the way the
long-running cartoon series depicted him
he said my treatment in The Simpsons was
always good humored I was depicted as a
somewhat surreal character with enormous
Powers Gene added that the reason he
scripted the late academic the way he
did was he saw him as a superstar in his
own right saying everyone wanted to get
their picture taken with him it was an
honor to be able to briefly interact
with the Albert Einstein of our time I
still can't get over it
hopes rumors and then actual news of a
movie based on the long-running TV
classic The Simpsons floated around for
years before The Simpsons movie was
released in 2007. it was worth the wait
a hilarious animated adventure with a
big story befitting the big screen the
film made more than 500 million dollars
at the worldwide box office it's been 10
years since everyone's favorite
four-fingered Springfield residents
proved they could make the jump from
television so how come they haven't made
The Simpsons Movie 2 yet a good idea the
show's writers and producers don't want
to attempt another big screen project
just for the sake of doing it it's such
a Monumental project with millions of
dollars at stake and millions of fans
with exacting standards that they'll
only make another Simpsons Movie if
they've got a really good idea one
that's really worth a 90-minute
treatment during a Simpsons panel at the
2016 San Diego Comic Con writer producer
Algin addressed the possibility of doing
another Simpsons Movie we talk about it
uh but it's you know if we do it we only
want to do it if it's going to be really
good
already used it at one point the writers
actually thought they had a great idea
for the next Simpsons Movie in an
episode initially conceived as the 24th
season finale Kang and kodos the
humongous booming voiced aliens that
have appeared in numerous Treehouse of
Horror Halloween specials kidnapped The
Simpsons family from Disneyland and take
them to their distant home planet of
rigel 7 where Homer is nearly eaten
algene who co-wrote the episode with
David Merkin decided with Simpson's
executive producer James L Brooks that
the plot was so ambitious that they
should use it for the next Simpsons
Movie Gene told Entertainment Weekly we
were worried that people might think
it's an idea that's not canonical
because the plot is so far gone from the
generally realistic scenarios of The
Simpsons the script went back into the
episode pile and aired as the man who
came to be dinner in 2015. too many
ideas perhaps the real problem isn't
that the Simpsons writers don't have a
good idea for a sequel is that they
can't pick just one for example before
they settled on the plot of the first
Simpsons movie The Riders floated
several large-scale movie worthy
Concepts the fourth season episode of
crusty in which Bard and Lisa attend a
terrifying decrepit summer camp that
descends into nightmarish chaos was
nearly a movie Matt Groening wanted to
make a Fantasia parody called semptasia
consisting of short animated sequences
set to music and before his death in
1998 Phil Hartman planned on making a
live-action film about his Simpsons
character B-movie actor Troy McClure he
can talk he can talk he can talk he can
talk I can sing mad Granite isn't
thrilled any Simpsons movie has to get
the sign off from Simpson's Creator and
executive producer Matt graning even 30
years after his characters debuted on
the Tracy Ullman Show he's still very
much involved with any and all major
decisions affecting his prize creation
and as far as a sequel goes he's in no
rush why the first one was a grind in a
2009 interview granny said the first
movie was an experience that left him
frustrated in part because he and other
members of the creative team thought it
would take two years to produce but it
ended up taking four while speaking at
UCLA Law School in 2013 graining said
the first film quote stole anime
animators from the show and drained
resources at the same speaking
engagement Simpson's producer and
director David Silverman estimated that
another movie would happen in another 10
15 years busy Simpsons James L Brooks
says Simpson's executive producer since
the show debuted in 1989 told The
Hollywood Reporter that The Simpsons
creative team hasn't made another movie
because they're doing a lot of other
stuff Brooks meant that whatever time
The Simpsons makers have for work
outside the show itself is spent on
Simpson's related extracurricular
activities such as a series of live
Simpsons shows at the Hollywood Bowl or
developing the scores of Simpson's bonus
material for The Simpsons World app it's
the all-young Simpsons Ride Happy Times
The Simpsons is still on TV probably the
main impediment preventing The Simpsons
Riders cast and crew from making another
Simpsons movie is The Simpsons the same
people who'd make another movie are
already pretty busy making 22 episodes
of the show every year that's a huge
workload episodes take months between
conception and full animation so each is
a lengthy and costly Endeavor involving
a small army of employees Simpson's
producer and director David Silverman
told Entertainment Weekly in 2017 that a
sequel is daunting because it really
knocked the stuffing out of us to do the
movie and the show at the same time if
the crew doesn't want to make a movie at
the same time as the show don't expect
that sequel anytime soon The Simpsons
has been renewed until at least 2019.
Fox hasn't ordered one yet while another
Simpsons Movie would be a Surefire hit
and a no-brainer for all involved the
fact remains at Studio 20th Century Fox
hasn't technically asked for one yet the
creative team isn't about to move
mountains to make another movie until
they're officially asked and contracts
are signed otherwise why work on
something that might not get made
anytime soon or ever nevertheless
Simpson's writer producer Al Jean says a
movie is in its earliest stages which
probably means the show's writers are
tossing around ideas and getting a game
plan together for if and win their
corporate bosses ever commission a
Simpsons Movie sequel keep those stubby
yellow fingers crossed
since its debut in 1989 The Simpsons has
broadcast over 600 episodes one more
than two dozen Emmys and a Peabody Award
and sold millions of dollars worth of
merchandise it's a pop culture
Juggernaut which means that there's a
small fortune of lore and behind the
scenes trivia out there about
Springfield's first family
pretty much the only adult Bart Simpson
actually respects is kids TV show host
Krusty the Clown when Matt Groening and
his writing staff were developing the
show early on however someone floated
the concept that Krusty and Homer were
actually going to be the same person as
granny told Entertainment Weekly the
original idea behind Krusty the Clown
was that he was Homer in Disguise but
Homer still couldn't get any respect
from his son who worshiped Krusty
unfortunately it became too complicated
a plot detail to work out once the show
was really getting off the ground so the
idea was abandoned but vestiges of the
Ark remain Krusty and Homer have an
almost identical character design Krusty
just has different hair and clown paints
and they're both voiced by the same
actor later on the sixth season episode
homie the clown references the original
idea and features Homer becoming a
Krusty the Clown impersonator
wow I'm sorry I doubted you before Dad
if there has to be a bastardized version
of crusty I'm glad it's you The Simpsons
rivalry with President George H.W bush
goes back a lot further than the
neighborhood dispute which erupts in
1996's two bad neighbors in a 1990
interview with people then first lady
Barbara Bush dismissed the show saying
it was the dumbest thing I had ever seen
in response the show's writers under the
guise of Marge Simpson sent Mrs Bush a
letter defending the show Marge wrote I
recently read your criticism on my
family I was deeply hurt heaven knows
we're far from perfect and if truth be
known maybe just a wee bit short of
normal but as Dr Seuss says a person is
a person Barbara apologized but things
didn't end there early in his 1992
re-election campaign President Bush told
the convention of National Religious
broadcasters we are going to keep on
trying to strengthen the American Family
to make American families a lot more
like The Waltons and a lot less like The
Simpsons a subsequent episode of The
Simpsons featured the family watching a
clip of Bush's speech
Waltons we're praying for an end to the
depression too in the season 3 episode
Stark raving dad Homer is mistakenly
sent to a psychiatric institution where
he's befriended by a hulking balding
patient named Leon who identifies
himself as Michael Jackson he certainly
had the voice of Michael Jackson because
the real king of Pop lent his voice to
the character who are you hi I'm Michael
Jackson from The Jacksons I'm Homer
Simpson from The Simpsons in the credits
however he was billed under the name
John J Smith so how did a relatively new
TV series land the biggest pop star in
the world Jackson simply phoned up and
asked a fan of the show Jackson at first
wanted to play himself but eventually
went with the writers when they
conceived the character of Leon
The Simpsons is one of the few
successful long-running TV shows to
never have generated a spin-off but it's
not for lack of trying in 1994 Matt
Groening wrote a script for a new series
that found Krusty the Clown getting his
own talk show and moving to Los Angeles
but it wasn't going to be a cartoon
grening wanted it to be a live action
series with Krusty's voice actor Dan
castellanetta reprising his role in the
flesh eventually graining accepted it
had to take the form of an animated
series instead because this whole thing
was just too expensive to pull off in
real life unfortunately the animated
show never saw the light of day either
after negotiations between graining and
fox stalled but creativity prevailed
granine's next project was a little show
about Earth in the year 3000. in late
1988 when The Simpsons was still just a
feature on the Tracy Ullman Show
producers made a deal with Butterfinger
for a commercial featuring Bart Simpson
the script called for BART to compare
lunches with a friend at school so
Simpson's staff filed through a series
of drawings that Granite had done for an
ultimately unproduced NBC Saturday
morning cartoon set in a Grade School
the one they picked to use as Bart's
foil was an especially nerdy looking kid
who remained unnamed in the commercial
he needed a name however if he was to
become part of The Simpsons proper
finally end of house but Milhouse is my
name but I thought I was the only one
the pain I know all too well why is he
named Milhouse according to graining I
named him Milhouse because I thought
that that was the most unfortunate name
I could think of for a kid
this is great and all I've done is
answer my name thrill house the episode
The Itchy and Scratchy and poochy show
parody The Once Common TV practice of
shows bringing in a cooler younger or
out of this world character to freshen
things up on The Simpsons it's Bart's
beloved Itchy and Scratchy cartoon which
adds poochie a sunglasses wearing
wrapping Surfer voiced by Homer Pucci
ends up a total flop with practically
everyone but Homer seen right through
the cheap ratings Ploy the premise is
paralleled in The Simpsons household
which suddenly includes a
never-before-seen sunglasses wearing
dude named Roy who at the end of the
episode moves out good news everybody
I'm moving into my own apartment with
two sexy ladies well then I guess this
is goodbye Roy Fox had recently tried to
do the same thing to The Simpsons before
the eighth season began Fox Executives
asked then showrunners Bill Oakley and
Josh Weinstein to add a new Fresh Face
To The Simpsons family the writers gave
them Roy and poochie instead as for
Poochie well he had the greatest
send-off ever I have to go now my Planet
needs me
The Simpsons isn't subject to the
regular rules of television and because
of that a lot of plots and Fates are
left dangling never to be resolved so
we're looking at some big questions at
the Simpsons posed over the years and
which it never fully answered
The Simpsons has been on so long that
its opening sequence is almost as famous
as the show itself with more than 600
episodes under its belt most Simpsons
fans could recall it from memory we've
got Bart writing a sentence on a
classroom Blackboard wall a few dozen
times as punishment Lisa getting kicked
out of band practice for playing jazz
Maggie getting picked up with Marge's
groceries and being swiped across a
cashier's Barcode Scanner and homework
cutting out of work when he hears the
whistle blow carelessly allowing a
nuclear Rod to bounce around after him
every one of these events warrants some
inspection Bard abandons the chalkboard
when he hears the school bell ring but
why does a bell ring when this is
obviously his after-school punishment
and why is Lisa's band class often
depicted as part of her regular school
day being held after class these events
suggest that it's about three or four
o'clock which seems early for Homer's
9-5 gig to end as for Maggie getting
scanned a price pops up for the grocery
cashier meaning Maggie is seemingly
wearing a barcode according to the
telegraph Simpson's Creator Matt Rainey
stated that the price that appears on
the register is is
847.63 it was the cost of raising a
child in 1989 when the show first
appeared on box
a running gag in the Simpsons wasn't
only hilarious wordplay but its
characterization of Bart Simpson as a
rude cynical Troublemaker art would call
Moe's Tavern and asked to speak with
someone and he'd always give a made-up
name that was either an insult or a pun
Moe would then call out to the assorted
bar flies see more Bots hey everybody I
wanna see more box
Bart would then descend into a fit of
giggles and realizing he'd been pranked
yet again Moe would threaten acts of
violence against the caller should he
ever discover their identity but most
should have figured out over a dozen
times at his frequent Frank caller is
the eldest Simpson child Homer is one of
most best customers and Moe is a family
friend but it's good that we the
audience get to enjoy his ongoing
confusion
see Montgomery Burns is the town villain
who owns the Springfield nuclear power
plant he once blocked the sun he stolen
puppies and he's incredibly old he's
fond of using old-timely insults like
thunderpaint answers the phone by saying
and tries to stack his company's
softball team with dead professional
baseball players Burns's age is clearly
just a vehicle for jokes and hilariously
archaic words but it doesn't make his
age clear his birth year has been given
both as 1881 and 1890 making him at
least 100 in The Simpsons universe but
in the season 4 episode last exit to
Springfield there's a flashback to Burns
as a boy in 1909 visiting an atom
smashing Mill as a school-aged boy
placing his birth around 1900 also in
the season 2 episode Simpson and Delilah
burns his age is said to be 81. although
in a few other episodes that age changes
to 104 and when Springfield's oldest man
dies at age 108 Burns takes his place he
could even be older but it's obvious
that the writers won't make it clear or
let this joke die
in the sixth season episode fear of
flying Homer is rewarded for helping an
airline hide its cover-up by mistaking
him for a pilot but the resulting trip
is canceled because Marge suffers a
panic attack while awaiting takeoff they
get off the plane and Marge sees the
psychiatrist to find the cause of her
fear of flying a repressed memory
reveals that Marge hates flying because
when she was very young she found out
her father was secretly a flight
attendant and not a pilot like she had
thought at the end of the episode Marge
is cured of her fear and gets on a plane
with a family only for it to run off the
Runway and crash into a lake Marge's
deep discomfort with Lion remains both
intact and Justified something which
doesn't mesh with events in earlier
Seasons The Simpsons family goes on to
take multiple vacations and trips via
airplane March included she never seems
to be anything but totally comfortable
and relaxed before enduring these air
voyages according to the Simpsons wiki
it's theorized that the episodes are out
of order which could explain March's
inconsistent Comfort lying
a permanent fixture at Moe's Tavern is
Barney Gumbel he's seemingly always
inebriated or in the process of becoming
inebriated Barney's obvious alcoholism
is a dark but frequent source of Comedy
he once won the Springfield film
festival with his beautiful and Haunting
movie about his battle with a bottle and
viewers learned that he had a promising
future until Homer gave him his first
beer the night before the SATs setting
Barney on a drunken path lacrimos is too
dyspeptic as a Boolean is to
effervescent
all right Harvard here I come in the
season 11 episode Days of Wine and dozes
Barney swears off beer joins Alcoholics
Anonymous and adjusts to a life in
recovery but his addictive Tendencies
still run deep and he still hangs out at
the bar because Mo buys an espresso
machine where after Barney eliminates
his dependency on alcohol by getting
hooked on caffeine a well-groomed Barney
is shown drinking latte after latte
until one day Barney is once more
permanently a slob knocking back
brewskis so what exactly LED Barney to
fall off the wagon and why unfortunately
we haven't gotten an answer yet
throughout the series Homer meets lots
of new people and invents makes or
schemes his way into just about
everything in the season 2 episode O
Brother Where Art Thou Homer's estranged
half-brother herb is a successful car
company owner who lets Homer design a
car that sets a flop and destroys the
company and leaves in destitute after
being homeless for a while herb returns
in the season three brother can you
spare two dimes and stays with the
Simpson family for a while until he gets
back on his feet with Maggie's help herb
develops a baby translator and it's an
instant success that makes him wildly
Rich once more to show his appreciation
he buys Homer the expensive luxury
recliner he's had his eye on this
episode hinges upon two very important
objects a device that unlocks the
language of infants and a huge piece of
furniture but the two objects are never
addressed again on The Simpsons a baby
translator would change the world but is
never mentioned again and hundreds of
scenes have transpired in The Simpsons
TV room with Homer firmly planted on the
couch and not his fancy chair
in the season 4 episode March versus the
monorail frivolously spending Town money
on a transit system seemed like such a
futuristic and Progressive idea it even
had a catchy song introduced by monorail
proprietor Lyle landley convincing them
to give landly the cash wind ball
collected from Mr Burns for crimes
against the environment of course the
monorail was a Civic financial and
political disaster but no ramifications
or Fallout ever seem to transpire not
only is Main Street still all cracked
and broken as March pointed out in the
monorail song but the town was left in
far worse shape when a makeshift anchor
to stop the runaway monorail ripped
through several streets and buildings
did Springfield fix all those roads and
if so how did the cash trap Town pay for
it are the monorail Towers tracks and
trains still hanging around Springfield
there is also the whereabouts of Lyle
landley to wonder about Mr Langley
aren't you gonna ride the monorail
little lady I'd love to but I have to
catch a plane but the ride Only Takes a
Minute yeah well my plane leaves in less
than one minute he built the monorail on
the cheap and escaped with the rest of
the cash only for his getaway plane to
perform an emergency landing in another
town he victimized where an angry mob
confronted him it's possible those Town
folk threw him in jail on charges of
criminal negligence but it still doesn't
account for the instantaneous recovery
of Springfield
the season 12 episode the computer wore
Men issues is undoubtedly one of the
strangest of The Simpsons catalog Homer
starts a website then spreads rumors and
conspiracy theories that he makes up
until he accidentally gets one right
when he tells the public that flu shots
are performed just before Christmas to
incite the massage to shop he's sent to
his strange spooky and surreal Island
prison among the occupants are a man who
invented a bottomless peanut bag Homer's
german-speaking doppelganger and a bunch
of menacing bubbles Homer manages to
escape and return home only to be
greeted by Santa's Little Helper who
sprays gas on him and the rest of the
family who later wake up in a state of
drugged out Bliss on the island then the
scene Fades to Black and the credits
roll the penal island is a lengthy
tribute to the bizarre 1960s British TV
series The Prisoner but this episode
isn't established like many Simpsons
Treehouse of four segments for all
viewers know the real Simpsons are still
on that island
The Simpsons has been on the air for 30
years and As Time Marches On people pass
away several longtime voice actors on
the series have died including Marshall
Wallace who voiced Springfield
Elementary teacher Edna krabappel and
Russi Taylor who voiced twins Sherry and
Terry and nerd Martin Prince Simpson's
writers have approached how to handle
character departures of deceased cast
members in different ways when Wallace
died Mrs krabappel died too and her
death was noticed and mourned in
particular by her husband Ned Flanders
when Taylor passed on her child
character survived voiced by new cast
member Greg DeLisle Griffin of course
the first big death on The Simpsons came
when Phil Hartman passed away in 1998.
producers opted to instantly retire his
recurring characters washed up B-movie
actor Troy McClure and Simpson family
attorney Lionel Hutz writers simply
didn't include the characters anymore
and neither was ever mentioned again
while we know the tragic details of
Apartments passing the fates of these
characters have never been discussed
the season 7 episode muchapoo about
nothing takes on the issues of
immigration or rather how politicians
blame government shortfalls on illegal
immigrants in Springfield this
transpires when a bear Patrol leads to a
tiny tax increase which upsets the
citizen so much that mayor Quimby blames
the new tax on immigrants voters then
decide on proposition 24 which would
immediately Deport every illegal
immigrant living in Springfield in fear
of the measure passing Kwik-E-Mart owner
and operator Apu frantically studies for
the citizenship test bartender MO is
also shown taking the test as his
stereotypical Italian chef Luigi a poo
passes and Mo and Luigi presumably do
too as both remain in town when prop 24
passes in a landslide however the
episode ends with a resentful
groundskeeper Willie on a boat dressed
in the style of a 19th century European
arriving at Ellis Island sailing away
from Springfield nevertheless Willy is
present in later episodes It's unclear
how he was able to return to town and
his job so quickly and easily it's not
clear if he took a citizenship tests are
arranged for legal immigration or if
he's somehow snuck back into Springfield
from Scotland
The Simpsons has always been a satirical
show holding an animated mirror up to
society to point out its ills and make
fun of them one target the show never
tires of our big corporations that do
bad things Homer works for the
Springfield nuclear power plants where
skirting environmental law in the name
of profits for owner Mr Burns is the
norm as a result Springfield is a
massively polluted and politically
corrupt Wasteland where the power plant
dumps toxic waste wherever it wants
while the local government gives only
the occasional small fine one of the
earliest episodes finds Burns's
gubernatorial campaign sidelined by a
three-eyed fish caught in a Waterway
polluted with waste toxic pollution is
just a part of life in Springfield but
is exposure to chemicals why all the
residents have sickly yellow skin
bulging eyes and four fingers on each
hand is it why they don't seem to age in
a normal way there certainly have been
even more ways that nuclear waste has
profoundly altered the lives of the
residents of Springfield and we're just
waiting for the Simpsons to answer those
burning questions
for more than 30 years The Simpsons has
skewered every major player in the pop
culture landscape including Marvel while
some of these superhero jokes are
obvious others aren't quite as easy to
spot here are some Marvel references in
The Simpsons that you might have missed
one of the earliest and best crusading
Lisa episodes of The Simpsons is Lisa vs
Malibu Stacy in this classic episode the
sensitive political and staunchly
feminist middle Simpson child Strikes
Back Against the manufacturers of a
barbie-like doll called Malibu Stacey in
the past Lisa was a huge Malibu Stacey
fan and collector but she becomes deeply
offended by a new talking version of the
doll it has a voice chip that delivers
an assortment of stereotypical phrases
such as let's make cookies for the boys
and don't ask me I'm just a girl Malibu
Stacy also utters this line which
further pushes Lisa to the edge
my makeup so the boys will like us at
this point Lisa rants to the other girls
about her issues with the doll a
confused classmate admits there's
something wrong with her Malibu Stacy
anybody call for a one-slinger this of
course is one of the phrases used by the
Marvel Comics character Spider-Man it's
also a much more obscure reference to an
early 90s activist group called the
Barbie Liberation Organization this
group secretly replaced the voice chips
of Mattel's Teen Talk Barbie which said
things like math class is tough in favor
of sayings from Talking GI Joe action
figures like eat lead Cobra and plenty
of other battle-ready expressions
The Simpsons has always been loaded with
side gags that only pop onto the screen
for a second or two making plenty of
these jokes easy to miss and whenever
The Simpsons family heads to a movie
viewers should keep a sharp eye on the
Marquee outside the theater because
there are likely to be a few clever
takes on popular film titles of course
Marvel has had more than a few of its
comic book characters and movie titles
Twisted by the writers of The Simpsons
for instance in the 2004 episode The zif
Who Came To Dinner there's a brief shot
of the theater's Marquee offering such
era specific fake films as the fashion
of the Christ eating Nemo and the
unwatchable Hulk the last one is a Sly
reference to the 2003 Hulk film the
first appearance of the angry green guy
on the big screen which was far from a
hit with the critics similarly in a 2018
episode The Simpsons go to see a film at
the capital city Googleplex along with
titles like Tran Transformers fatigue
and the Lego get out movie there's a
film called Marvel letters to the editor
a dig at how the company has used
seemingly everything from its Comics
Canon as movie fodder
after watching a Marvel film The
Simpsons stick around for the credits
which mentioned that Mark Ruffalo who
plays the Hulk has an anger coach and
that Stan Lee was created by Stan Lee's
parents however as we all know Marvel
movies are never really over when the
credit start to roll and this animated
parody is no exception The Simpsons make
fun of the mcu's love of mid-credit and
post-credit sequences that reveal huge
plot twists and wet audience appetites
by setting up future movies Marvel
letters to the editor has a mid-credit
scene that brings a beloved character
back from the dead in this case it's
Peter Parker's Uncle Ben only now he's
unspeakably evil and revealed is the
film's villain after that there's yet
another sequence which sets things up
for an avengers-like movie featuring the
assemblers who the hell are you I'm
assembling a team of the best team
assemblers in the world and I want you
to help me put together bad team
plenty of Marvel movies have been origin
stories such as the 2002 Spider-Man
which tells how Peter Parker became a
web-slinging wall crawling superhero and
many elements of this Sam Raimi film are
gently parodied in simple Simpson a 2004
episode which serves as the origin story
for Homer's short-lived superhero
identity pie man it all starts at the
county fair where Lisa enters a table
setting contest unfortunately the judge
an obnoxious Rich Texan thinks her
project stinks like the south end of a
Northbound mule and goes about
humiliating her for his own
entertainment when Homer sees his
daughter being mocked by the judge he
becomes angry to the point of violence
however remembering that Chief Wiggum
told him he'd go to jail if he committed
another felony assault Homer takes
another path to Vengeance he steals
items from various bare booths and
Fashions them into a crude superhero
outfit announcing himself elf as pie Man
and Avengers Lisa by throwing a pie in
the rich Texans face before Homer can
write any other wrongs he needs a proper
Pie costume the episode then launches
into a montage of Homer drawing up ideas
for his pie man look then dutifully
sewing one together it doesn't look
quite as good as what he'd probably
imagined the whole thing is reminiscent
of Peter Parker creating his own less
than Stellar first outfit in Spider-Man
this Simpsons episode has another big
reference to the film with an upside
down kiss between pie man and Marge
I'm looking up your nose but I feel like
I'm staring into your soul
Mona Lisa from 2006 is a truly classic
episode of The Simpsons in that it gives
viewers its signature mix of references
to highbrow interests and accessible pop
culture renowned authors Jonathan
Franzen Michael chabon Tom Wolfe and
Gore Vidal make voice cameos while
there's also an Extended sequence
involving a side character from this
spider verse specifically as he was
presented in the first Trilogy of
Spider-Man movies during the episode
Lisa discovers that Mo the bartender is
a dark sad Everyman poet in the vein of
Charles Bukowski and she sends his work
to the literary journal American Poetry
perspectives and who happens to be the
Magazine's editor it's none other than
Jay Jonah Jameson who's apparently moved
on from his job at the Helm of the Daily
Bugle I need photos photos of Spider-Man
man this is a poetry Journal okay then
poems about Spider-Man Jameson is voiced
by Academy award-winning character actor
JK Simmons who portrayed him in the Toby
Maguire Spider-Man movies as well as
Spider-Man far from home references to
comic books and its surrounding culture
have been part of The Simpsons for
decades even back when collecting Comics
was a relatively Niche Pastime Bart
Simpson and Milhouse regularly visit
Springfield's comic Source the Androids
dungeon and baseball card shop run by
the usually arrogant and dismissive
Comic Book Guy however in the episode
but where am I cheating Bart two of
Springfield's young residents wind up at
the store not for comic books but for a
romantic Refuge the trouble starts when
neighborhood bully Jimbo forces BART to
escort his girlfriend Shauna to places
he doesn't want to go and the true
developed romantic feelings for each
other after they're caught kissing at
the public pool Barton Sean a hide from
Jimbo and his bully friend at the
Android's Dungeon Comic Book Guy greets
them with words that would make any Thor
fan feel at ease think of this as your
personal Asgard and I the All-Seeing
Heimdall guardian of the gate that's
three references to Norse mythology in
one sentence but since this is Comic
Book Guy it's safe to assume that he's
referring to the Norse mythology
inspired world of Marvel's Thor but wait
there's one more Marvel reference in
this scene after Shauna makes fun of
comic book guys wait he alerts Jimbo and
the bullies where she's hiding Shauna
then starts a flame war with him and he
drops a classic Marvel lion oh flame on
even casual fans will recognize flame on
as the catchphrase of the Human Torch
from the Fantastic Four
embossed the bad guy Bart becomes the
most powerful person in Springfield
after he watches an advanced copy of the
superhero Saga vindicators Crystal War 2
Resurgence he was able to view it on a
laptop that he lifted from a drunk
passed out star of the film now Bart can
get anything he wants by threatening to
reveal spoilers for the highly
anticipated Blockbuster clearly the film
is a send-up of Avengers Infinity war
and end game complete with a powerful
space Titan and emotional Cliffhanger
the episode starts with just about
everyone in Springfield watching the
first Crystal war movie in the film's
final climactic scene the Thanos like
Chinos comes into possession of the
Doomsday app which he used to turn the
protagonists into crystals that shadow
like Infinity War the crystal War films
are overloaded with superheroes most of
which have easily identifiable Marvel
counterparts for instance there's The
Simpsons version of Iron Man magnesium
man who is always ready with a witty bit
of dialogue another main character in
the episode is air shot he's clearly
based on Hawkeye except instead of being
an expert Archer he's mastered the pump
action air gun
[Music]
yes airshot pump that air gun five pumps
think of the pressure the episode is
packed with visual references to recent
Marvel movies but it also throws in a
musical nod to one of their films from
the previous decade during one scene we
hear the song People Get Up and Drive
your funky Soul while Bart walks down
the hall of his school this is the same
James Brown tune that accompanies Peter
Parker's Infamous strike down the street
in 2007 Spider-Man 3. in Elementary
School Musical an episode from 2010
Krusty the Clown achieves the
unthinkable he wins the Nobel Peace
Prize however it's all just a ruse to
get him onto a plane which lands at the
Hague where Krusty is arrested and is
set to be Tried by the international
court of justice he'll be released only
if someone can find proof that Krusty
has contributed significantly to culture
in any way Homer and Bart scrambled to
locate some kind of evidence of Krusty's
artistic importance after scouring the
internet they find her my tube clip of
the PBS educational show The Electric
Company The Simpsons version of the show
features a character who seems to be
inspired by easy reader who was
portrayed on the real Electric Company
by a young Morgan Freeman predictably
Krusty's appearance on the show goes
completely Haywire gotta hide me I slept
with the lighting director's wife
[Music]
this is a deep Marvel cut as a low
budget version of Spider-Man really did
appear on the electric company in the
70s
the 2017 episode Springfield Splendor
alludes to the title of the classic
Indie comic American Splendor but on the
whole the episode satirizes all kinds of
comic books and other properties they've
spawned in recent years after Lisa
writes a confessional autobiographical
novel called sad girl as art therapy
Comic Book Guy publishes it without her
permission you published my private art
therapy as a comic book
um actually it's a graphic novel The
distinctions are threefold shut up
however the graphic novel becomes a hit
and Lisa is invited to be on a panel at
Comic-Con like real life pop culture
conventions attendees dress as their
favorite comic book and movie characters
there's a brief shot of a fan wearing a
cheap ramshackle tree costume clearly
he's attempting to cosplay as Groot from
Guardians of the Galaxy also it looks
like Stan Lee is in the background later
in the episode Lisa's sad girl gets
turned into a musical which is
ostensibly a stand-up of the graphic
novel to Broadway success of Alison
bechdel's fun home also the score for
the sad girl live experience is the same
score from the ill-fated Broadway
musical Spider-Man turn off the dark
the late Stan Lee was basically
synonymous with Marvel Comics he was a
lifelong cheerleader for the company
where he helped invent dozens of
legendary characters it was only fitting
that he turned in an extended cameo in a
Simpsons episode that finds Bart
becoming a major player in the comics
business after Bart visits the Android's
Dungeon to get comic book guy's opinion
on a character he created Lee offers up
his own expert critique when Bart
returns to the store later he notices
that Lee is still hanging around Comic
Book Guy posits that Lee's mind is no
longer in mint condition which is
Illustrated when he's trying to convince
a customer that an action figure of the
thing can fit into a much smaller
Batmobile later in the episode Homer
becomes enraged after falling into an
inflatable pool filled with green paint
and is mistaken for the Hulk when Lee
sees this happening he can't help but
get involved I'm the Hulk
oh please you couldn't even change to
build Bixby 12 Seasons later a vision of
Lee tries to convince Comic Book Guy to
pursue the girl he loves when he asks
for help Lee declines and says I can
only watch I cannot interfere that's a
subtle nod to a bit of dialogue spoken
by the Watchers the Marvel characters
seen in Guardians of the Galaxy and
Fantastic Four however when Comic Book
Guy starts to lose his nerve the vision
of Lee returns to lend a helping hand
come on Nick ask her out you're
interfering hey I'm 90 years old I can
do what I want
the chalkboard gag in the intro to The
Simpsons has become an iconic sight in
TV comedy and over the years Bart
Simpson has written a whole heap of
words on that chalkboard from
controversial political statements to
in-jokes to colorful innuendos these are
Bart's most Savage chalkboard jokes
it's not easy being a teacher even
putting aside the low pay and awful
working conditions you've sometimes got
to deal with students like Bart Simpson
after all Bart's penchant for stirring
up trouble is the reason why he's
perpetually writing lines in the first
place time and again he's ruthlessly
attacked the faculty of Springfield
Elementary School with smart mouth
remarks devious pranks and wisecracks
Bart's teacher Edna krabappel has
especially suffered at Bart's hands as
seen in his rather questionable remarks
concerning her appearance in the intro
for the episode The zif Who Came To
Dinner other Bart chalkboard notes
regarding Mrs krabappel include I will
not call my teacher hotcakes I will not
mock Mrs dumb face and I will not hide
the teacher's Prozac Bart has even
remarked on Mrs krabapple's love life
such as when he was forced to admit that
teacher was not dumped it was mutual and
over 40 in single is not funny
ouch
during The Simpsons time on television
the show has become infamous for
predicting the Future IT mocked the idea
of using chemicals found in gym mats as
hidden fillers in processed foods all
the way back in 1995 which grossly
enough turned out to be true in 2014.
Homer Simpson even got pretty close to
guessing the weight of the recently
discovered Higgs boson particle in
1998's the Wizard of Evergreen Terrace
but the Simpsons made one of its most
notorious predictions to date in BART to
the Future which originally aired in
2000 the episode takes place in the year
2030 when Lisa has just become president
of the United States and is facing some
economic difficulties thanks to the
previous commander-in-chief as you know
we've inherited quite a budget crunch
from president Trump shortly after
Trump's election to the presidency the
show referenced its own uncanny
prediction with the chalkboard gag in
which BART writes being right sucks
many of Bart's Chalkboard quotes are
peppered with evocative innuendos and
playful puns he apparently couldn't stop
talking about the 12-inch pianist in
Marge be not proud and makes a
non-to-ser mix a lot when he notes
Sherry does not got back in Wild Barts
can't be broken among some of his more
colorful innuendos you've got Bart
vowing not to hang Donuts on his person
promising not to make fun of Cupid's
Dink and acknowledging that pork is not
a verb Bart also shares some of his
rejected words of wisdom in 101
mitigations when he is seen writing
chili fries do not go in like a lamb and
out like a lion but things get taken to
the next level during the opening
sequence for the episode pray anything
in which BART scribbles out SpongeBob is
not a contraceptive Gotta Give the kid
credit for creativity don't you
Bart certainly gets up to his fair share
of shenanigans and if the show's
chalkboard gags are anything to go by
they don't all happen on screen over the
years some of Bart's prank based
chalkboards have included I will not
yell fire in a crowded classroom I will
not yell she's dead during roll call and
the Pledge of Allegiance does not end
with hail Satan he apparently harassed a
blind person by promising to return the
seeing eye dog in whacking day and vowed
he wouldn't put hot sauce in the CPR
dummy at the start of Father Knows worst
Bart has also expressed a rather more
worrying side to his class Romantics
including writing five days is not too
long to wait for a gun non-flammable is
not a challenge and hooligan is not a
profession one of Bart's most notable
moments of chalkboard Mischief hails
from the episode doe Canada Bart writes
haha on the Blackboard then hits it
which rotates to reveal Nelson taped to
the other side Who's Laughing Now
the writers on The Simpsons are no
strangers to getting meta and this is
usually most noticeable during the
show's opening sequences and of course
the chalkboard gags for example there's
the time when Bart cut corners while
writing I will not cut Corners by only
writing the line out six times and
filling out the remaining lines with
ditto quotation marks he also slightly
remarks this punishment is not boring
and pointless and Camp crusty and writes
I'm sorry I broke the Blackboard on a
whiteboard in black-eyed please in
reference to how critics describe South
Park when it first aired Bart writes I'm
not Charlie Brown on acid in the blunder
years he also poked fun at The Simpsons
Itself by writing I will not celebrate
meaningless Milestones when the show was
airing its 100th episode after
Butterfinger canceled their Simpsons ad
campaign because the brand had been the
butt of some of the show's jokes Bart
responded by writing I will not bite the
hand that feeds me Butterfingers then
when the Simpsons Hit the big screen and
got their own movie in 2007 Bart
promised not to illegally download this
movie in its intro he also joked that he
will never win an Emmy in Homer's bar
barbershop quartet even though by that
point the show had already won nine
throughout 2020 the United States and
the rest of the world faced the first
waves of the covid-19 pandemic seemingly
overnight countless people found
themselves struggling to adapt to a new
way of life in an attempt to stem the
tide many offices went virtual and so
did schools parents everywhere suddenly
found themselves trying to help their
children navigate online classrooms and
curricula and from the looks of it not
even The Simpsons were immune to the
chaos of the coronavirus pandemic as a
way to honor these drastic changes The
Simpsons modified its chalkboard gag for
an episode that aired on April 19 2020
during the intro to the incredible
lightness of being a baby Bart's
classroom is empty and a single line on
the board reads School online a poignant
nod to the dramatic events that would
have resonated with students parents and
teachers everywhere
Ralph Wiggum is one of The Simpsons
stranger and most endearing characters
sure he's a perfectly sweet little boy
but he's also incredibly odd and about
as brainless as you can get that's where
I saw the leprechaun ride a leprechaun
told me to burn things
of course Bart is well aware of Ralph's
many quirks and is constantly teasing
him for it even during the show's
chalkboard gags in the intro to fear of
flying Bart writes Ralph won't morph if
you squeeze him hard enough a reference
to the color morphing stress balls that
were popular at the time the show aired
one of Bart's more Savage notes
concerning his odd classmate can be seen
in Apocalypse cow in which he writes a
person's a person no matter how Ralph
class pets are a fun way to reinforce
the lessons they're taught in school as
well as help students experience the
responsibility of taking care of a small
life in fact Studies have also shown
that pets in the classroom have positive
impacts on student Behavior enhanced
social interaction and student attitudes
not that you'd know it looking at Bart
those poor poor hamsters there have been
a handful of class hamsters featured on
The Simpsons over the years including
nibbles the hamster who bravely helped
save those trapped inside the school in
Skinner sense of snow and even made it
to space and back in she of little faith
regardless of their heroism however Bart
has relentlessly mocked his class
hamsters during the show's chalkboard
gags during the intro to Homer the
Whopper Bart writes the class hamster
isn't just sleeping and in day of the
Jack and apes he notes the hamster did
not have a full life yikes get in that
ball and run for the hills little
hamster godspeed nibbles godspeed nuts
being a parent is a massive blessing but
it can also be incredibly frustrating
and having a kid like Bart must make it
even harder to exercise discipline still
that doesn't exactly excuse Homer's
particular approach to Parenting that is
strangling Bart whenever he loses his
patience luckily this is just a cartoon
which generally makes Homer's
strangulations more humorous than
horrific still this is one aspect of the
show that hasn't aged too well over the
last 30 years and even though it's set
in the context of the show's
off-the-wall humor it can still be a
tough pill to swallow and this problem
is eloquently touched upon during the
chalkboard gag for Frank gets testy in
which Homer can be seen writing
strangling is not an effective parenting
tool as a smug Bart watches on
during the show's time on television The
Simpsons has stirred up plenty of
controversy surrounding religion one
obvious example of this is Ned Flanders
who is a constant Target for jokes about
Christianity but one of the more subtle
ways the show has poked fun at religion
over various episodes is through the use
of March Chalkboard quotes in the intro
to the burns and the bees Bart writes
Jesus is not mad his birthday is on
Christmas and in reality bites he notes
there was no Roman god named farticus
but one of his darkest and funniest
remarks comes during the intro to dark
knight court in which BART writes
Jesus's last words were not TGIF
in a world like The Simpsons mothers are
the cornerstones of their households and
that goes doubly for Marge Simpson mom
you're always trying to give me potatoes
what is it with you I just think they're
neat but even though Marge loves Bart
unconditionally he can definitely make
things difficult at times just take his
attitude to Mother's Day for example
over the years Bart has lambasted that
particular Holiday by writing things
such as today is not mothra's day eating
my vegetables is not a Mother's Day
present and dirty clothes are not a
Mother's Day gift in the intro to Homer
Scissorhands he even writes I do not
deserve a Mother's Day gift for being
one badass mother but hey maybe it's not
all that bad during the intro to Ned and
Edna's blend in one of his more Lucid
moments Bart writes call your mother
during the commercials
during the 25th season of The Simpsons
executive producer Al Jean dropped a
massive bombshell on fans that in the
near future they'd be killing off a
major character the writers had
initially planned for the death to take
place later that season but in the end
they had to delay it until the show's
26th season this delay only stirred The
public's interest that much more and for
months Simpsons fans were left in a
state of deep suspense Furious
speculation and rumors circulated across
the internet over who exactly The
Unlucky Soul would be many suspected
Krusty the Clown as being the doomed
character but when the episode clown in
the dumps finally did air it turned out
his father Rabbi Hyman kristofsky was
the long-hinted character who would
ultimately pass away playing up to fans
speculation about the long-awaited
episode the show opens with an equally
memorable chalkboard gag in his typical
ruthless fashion Bart Wright's spoiler
alert unfortunately my dad doesn't die
another major Simpsons character who
passed away on the show is Bart's
teacher Edna krabappel during season 25
the actor who voiced the character
Marcia Wallace passed away as a humble
way of paying respect to Wallace's
memory Bart's normally Savage tone was
tamed for the chalkboard gag opening the
episode following Wallace's passing in
four regretings and a funeral a solemn
looking Bart writes just one line on the
chalkboard we'll really miss you Mrs k
in the interest of exercising our inner
Comic Book Guy it's worth taking a look
back at The Simpsons and examining some
of the problematic moments that everyone
except the most nitpicky of Simpsons
fans were willing to overlook in this
season 9 episode Lisa the Simpson Lisa
begins to fear that her gift of
intelligence is failing her no I can't
remember my combination
look at my agriculture project it's a
piece of a cow when she complains to Abe
he tells her that every member of the
Simpson family starts out smarts but
then dramatically becomes dumber with
age sending Lisa into an anxious spiral
that she fears she'll soon become oafish
like her father and brother when Homer
realizes what his dad has done he calls
the extended family over where they
discover that the gene only affects the
Simpson men a female relative who's a
doctor explains the leads so that the
defective genius and the Y chromosome
meaning only boys get it along with a
rodent figure and a bold head although
this makes Lisa feel better it presents
a plot hole in the form of Homer's
previously introduced half-brother her
Powell the product of an affair between
Aben a woman named Gabby herb was put up
for adoption in Shelbyville when Homer
meets her for the first time as an adult
he's introduced as a highly successful
businessman who puts himself through
Harvard and climbed the ranks to start
his own automotive company Herbert's
Rich intelligent and successful he is
all the things that Abe's jeans were
supposed to go away as he got older so
the Simpson jeans seemingly skipped her
for unknown reasons but herb actually
may not have missed a Simpson Gene
entirely he was convinced to make a
terrible car by his half-brother Homer
and fell victim to short bursts of anger
and clumsiness Maybe by virtue of being
adopted some nurture helped counteract
his nature
in the season sixth episode Lisa's
wedding the family attends a fair where
Lisa stumbles upon a fortune teller and
agrees to let the woman tell her a story
of her first love for the first time in
the show's history the audience has
presented with a Flash Forward showing a
23 year old Lisa embarking on a
whirlwind romance with a young British
student named Hugh Parkfield their
wedding ceremony in Springfield is
ill-fated after Hughes simply can't
handle the oafish nature of Lisa's
family she calls off the wedding but not
before friends and family gather for the
ceremony including Maude Flanders and
Edna krabapple although it's the year
2010 at the time 15 years in the future
from the episodes air date fans know
that both characters met unfortunate
tens while Lisa was still in second
grade Maude was famously killed by a
t-shirt Blaster Homer provoked at a race
car event when the velocity of the blow
knocked her off the top of the Raceway
that sent her husband Ned Flanders on a
journey of grief in which he tried to
figure out how to move on as a single
father the episode aired in 2000 long
before these future wedding would have
taken place Ned would eventually move on
with krabapple but when the voice
actress who played her Marsha Wallace
died in 2013 the show retired her
character by killing Edna off screen as
a result both characters would not be
able to attend 23 year old Lisa's
wedding however Lisa's wedding is about
a possible future not an actual one so
in that alternate timeline both
characters made it to 2010. in the
season 12 episode Homer Homer subjects
himself to medical testing after blowing
the family's savings on a faulty
investment the doctors discovered that
Homer's complete lack of intelligence
isn't biological at all but rather the
result of a crayon getting accidentally
lodged into his brain after he attempted
to stick an entire 16 pack up his nose
as a child Mr Simpson this could be
responsible for your subnormal
intelligence hey I came here to be
drugged electrocuted and probe not
insulted Homer's lack of intelligence
was already explained through the
Simpson Gene as a genetic predisposition
to stupidity however when he agrees to
let doctors remove the crayon his IQ
shoots up significantly the intelligence
at Homer gains endears him to Lisa but
makes him a villain realizing that he
can't handle the burden Homer enlists
the help of unlicensed surgeon Mo the
bartender to insert a crayon back into
his brain Lisa briefly protests but is
subdued by a letter left behind by the
intelligent version of her father
however Majin barter never seen reacting
to his elective brain damage image and
he now lives as an unintelligent burden
on the rest of them no one does a
sensible thing and implores him to
consider the long-term effects every
moment of homeless stupidity from that
moment forward is not the Charming oh
fishness of a cartoon character but the
choice of a selfish man with
self-induced brain damage because the
Simpsons has been on for 30 years
without aging any of its characters it's
hard to pin down the time frame in which
major events happened the show typically
only calls it out when it's played for
comedy characters don't have any deep
meaning they're just stupid drawings
they give you a cheap laugh but all bets
are off when it comes to the timeline of
Martin Homer's relationship in three key
episodes It's revealed that Martin
Homer's courtship lasted through the
1980s 1990s and early 2000s in the
season 2 episode the way we was it's
revealed that Homer and Marge met in
1974 while they were both attending
Springfield High School one season later
while telling the story of how Bart was
born it is implied that they conceived
him after watching The Empire Strikes
Back which hit theaters in 1980 the two
you married while Marge was pregnant
however in the season 19 episode that
90s show Homer and Marge tell their kids
of how they briefly separated in the
early 90s still before Bart was born and
they were married in that time Homer
invented Grunge music or Marge pursuit
of romance with a college professor
which would mean she was attending
college more than a decade after
graduating high school all of that goes
out the window in the season 29 episode
three scenes plus attack from a marriage
when home run Marge revealed that Bart
was born or they were living in capital
city in the early 2000s when talking
plot holes in The Simpsons you really
can't miss a reality busting season 9
episode the principal and the Pauper in
this episode it's revealed that Seymour
Skinner was actually an imposter named
Armin tamzarian when Armin got in
trouble with the law while living as a
street punk in capital city he was
forced into the army where he met the
real Skinner after Skinner was
presumably killed in action tamzarian
went to Springfield to break the news to
his mother only to be mistaken for his
mentor unable to break the bad news he
lived to Skinner for the next 20 years
the episode ends with the town allowing
tamzarian to continue his principle and
agreeing to never speak of it again but
there's evidence that the man who says
he's tamzarian is irrefutably Skinner in
the season 3 episode Bart's friend falls
in love it's revealed that Seymour spent
18 months on the prisoner of war and a
season 7 episode raging Abe Simpson and
his grumbling grandson in the curse of
the flying hellfish is revealed that
Skinner's grandfather Sheldon Skinner
was an Abe Simpsons platoon in World War
II when Sheldon is shown in a flashback
he appears to be in mistakable relative
of the man who stole the Skinner
identity
at one point in this series it's
revealed that Homer grew up on a farm
off of rural route 9. in subsequent
episodes the family used to produce
Dairy until Homer spooked all the cows
one day as a child and they stopped
producing milk and the rest of the land
wouldn't grow anything after they have a
fight in season 6 Homer and Abe
accidentally burned the house down
completely they even embraced on the
porch after an argument as the rest of
the Farmhouse turns to Rubble behind
them but the old Simpson Farm apparently
doesn't stay burned down in their season
11 episode eiei doe Homer becomes
obsessed with challenging people to
duels when he Brazen these challenges a
southern Duelists Homer makes a quick
escape and brings his family to his old
farmhouse which is miraculously still
standing with no explanation whatsoever
the episode simply continues on and sees
Homer invent the refreshingly addictive
tobacco crop that sprouted us tomatoes
without ever letting the audience in in
what happened with the fire the
prevailing Theory to explain the
reappearing Simpson farm so the episodes
actually happened out of order and that
the farm would still be standing while
Homer prepares for a stall in the later
episode
in the season 6 episode fear of flying
The Simpsons family earned themselves a
free trip anywhere on the continental
United States in exchange for their
Silence about Thomas gross incompetence
while impersonating a pilot they're
thrilled except for March who freaks out
before takeoff revealing a lifelong fear
of flying
this thing goes through therapy the rest
revealed that she was disappointed in
her father at a young age After figuring
out that he was a male flight attendant
and not a pilot like she thought she
also had repressed memories of being
poked in the eye while being fed by the
airplane as a baby and a toy ride on
airplane blowing up as well as a memory
of being shot at in a cornfield by a
low-flying plane in the end the Marge is
able to get back on the plane but it
overshoots the runway and lands on the
water however what makes this a glaring
plot hole is the fact that Marge flew
without incident in the season 3 episode
Mr Lisa Goes to Washington not only does
Marge accompany the family on a flight
but their particular flight was likely
triggering for anyone with a fear of
flying Bart made his way to the cockpit
and released everyone's oxygen masks as
a prank all the same Marge handles the
flight well she's still over her fear
later in season 6 when the entire family
travels to Australia but this could be
explained that the episodes are again
out of order and Marge being over her
fear in the later episodes means therapy
worked and stayed with her in the season
11 episode kill the alligator and run
the Simpson family inadvertently takes a
trip to Florida during spring break
Homer gets wrapped up in the celebration
and ends up accidentally running over
the local community's mascot an
alligator named Captain Jack the law
shows up and the family is allowed to
leave the state provided that they never
return the episode ends The Simpsons
Crossing Florida off a map of states had
been banned from re-entering but their
expulsion from Florida apparently
doesn't last forever in the season 14
episode Special Edna the family
accompanies Bart's teacher to Orlando
after he nominates her for a teacher of
the year award and she subsequently wins
the family travels to and from the
fictional efcart Center without incident
and in a season 15 episode catch him if
you can Homer and Marge make the hasty
decision to go on a second honeymoon to
Miami prompting Bart and Lisa to come
accompanied by Abe this certainly cool
to the end of their spring break
Adventure into question as it was either
based completely on lies or simply
unenforced by the states but the show
known for its satire may be calling the
state of order out for comedy's sake it
simply wouldn't be a good show if Homer
Simpson wasn't able to try out one-off
career opportunities every chance he
gets it does pose certain logistical
problems for him the family and the
show's sense of continuity the series
posed fun of this plus hole in the
season 13 episode Papa's Got a Brand New
badge where Homer takes up a job as a
private security business that is
eventually granted full policing Powers
Over Springfield as March does her
nightly hair routine homo discusses his
many occupations boxer mascot astronaut
imitation Krusty baby proofer trucker
hippie plow driver food critic
conceptual artist Greece salesman
Kearney mayor grifter and he goes on and
on listing many more which raises the
question how is Homer quitter's power
plant job and subsequently returned so
many times throughout the years it could
be theorized that Homer is simply bad at
his job and so low on the corporate
ladder that no one notices as prolonged
absences Tunes don't have to be 100
realistic
with nearly 100 Treehouse of Horror
segments produced and aired at this
point some rank right up there with both
the best ever moments on The Simpsons
and perhaps even with the creepy tales
that inspired them watch on to
experience the very best Treehouse of
Horror installments if you dare
the uniting theme of Treehouse of Horror
2 is that if you eat too much Halloween
candy some bad dreams will definitely
follow despite any warnings though The
Simpsons kids and Homer go overboard
so follows Bart's nightmare a parody of
the good life one of the most famous
episodes of The Twilight Zone
the proud underachiever dreams that he
can both read minds and manipulate
reality with a thought as a result all
of Springfield fears even having a
negative thought about bart lest he
deliver repercussions
he uses his power to fulfill even his
most mundane wishes for example when
Homer refuses to turn off a football
game for the Krusty the Clown show Bart
makes Homer the game ball and he flies
into a goal post when an angry Homer
tries to smash a bark with a chair the
boy mentally transforms him into a
jack-in-the-box Mars tires of the
fighting and sends the two to Dr Marvin
Monroe for some much needed family
therapy and the doc tells Barton Homer
to spend more time together
that leads to a montage of wholesome
activities that's hilariously out of
place in a Halloween episode complete
with fishing baseball and church the
positive attention from Homer which he
may desperately need in regular life
renders his powers less effective and
brings them together for some genuine
fatherly affection that's so horrifying
to Bart that he wakes up screaming
maybe they should try that therapist in
real life
Bart Simpson has always been a
troublemaker and in the eighth season
Treehouse of Horror segment the thing
and I Simpsons writers provided a
logical reason why Bart is so bad
he's evil it all starts when Bart and
Lisa hear spooky monster noises in the
attic and they're only more Curious when
Homer carts off a bucket of fish heads
to feed something he calls
it
that it turns out to be a he and he
escapes its shackles among the attic's
many unsold copies of B Sharp's records
and Homer's autobiography finally Marge
along with Dr Hibbert clues in the kids
explaining that Bart was born as part of
a pair of conjoined twins and that the
other one which they named Hugo was pure
evil a fact confirmed by Medical Science
but what to do with poor Hugo too crazy
for boys town too much of a boy for
Crazy Town the child was an outcast the
only solution was for the Simpson family
to embrace the time otter traditions of
Gothic horror and chain evil Hugo in the
Attic occasionally feeding him some fish
heads that's when Hugo returns with
plans to sew himself back to his twin
only for Dr Hibbert to save the day
well not for Bart as the doc realizes
that Bart was the evil twin all along
and then forces him into a life as the
secret restrained attic child and grants
the weird maladjusted Hugo his freedom
I know what you did Italy Italy did
parody the trendy teen horror movies of
the late 90s particularly and obviously
I Know What You Did Last Summer if you
missed it that movie concerns a group of
young people who accidentally run a guy
over and cover it up only to be haunted
by the dead man The Simpsons version
opens with a misdirect as The Simpsons
drive along a twisty Road on a foggy
night having already escaped vampires
who'd stolen their super sugar crisp
obviously but it just so happens that
they're driving down the same road where
neighborino Ned Flanders is enjoying one
of his famous fog walks
and that's where Marge hits him quick
and kill the flanners by accident even I
have my doubts instead of calling the
authorities Homer engages in a Twisted
round of Weekend at Bernie's Recreation
hauling around Ned's rotten corpse to
Stage a fake death and take the heat off
of Marge after the funeral her Homer
basically confesses the family is
haunted by a man in a raincoat with a
hook and they flee to a series of spooky
horror movie locales until the
mysterious stalker reveals himself it's
Ned of course
but it turns out Marge didn't kill him
after all
he was never dead because he's already
Undead having been turned into a
werewolf earlier that night the moral of
the story
stay out of the dang fog
in this segment from the sixth Treehouse
of Horror special The Simpsons ramps up
the satire skewering the crassness of
outdoor advertising while also taking
Homer to task for his gluttony
when he buys a colossal-sized donut at
lard lad that turns out to be only
slightly larger than a regular pastry
Homer gets so angry that he steals the
giant metal donut held Aloft by the
store's 50-foot tall mascot statue
unfortunately this active vandalism
coincides with an ionic disturbance
which jolts lard lad and other massive
tacky advertising characters to life
including parodies of Mr Peanut the Pep
Boys mascot and even the Simpson's own
Kent Brockman
needless to say these commercially
motivated Horrors immediately wreak
havoc on Springfield devastating the
town in Revenge for Homer's theft the
police are no help of course and a joke
that feels way too Grim for The Simpsons
Chief Wiggum shoots at the first tall
thing he sees which turns out to be a
high school basketball player it's up to
our favorite family to set things right
so Lisa consults an old advertising
executive who explains that since the
mascots are commercials the only way to
stop them is By ignoring them
they further enlist the aid of 60s pop
crooner Paul Anka who writes an anti-add
jingle to convince spring fieldians to
just don't look fighting the ads with
ads of their own the tactic works and
the Raging monsters fall over and die
right onto the orphanage in Children's
Hospital crushing them in the process
the moral of the story you can't win
them all
even the scariest of the Treehouse of
Horror segments lean on the comical side
from what we can tell a ratio of three
parts funny to one part scary seems to
roughly approximate The Simpsons
writer's formula however every so often
one of these Halloween installments is
downright scary if not gruesome
Nightmare on Evergreen Terrace is both
of those things and still manages to be
funny Bart dreams that a Freddy
krueger-esque rake wielding
groundskeeper Willie tries to kill him
and he wakes up with rake wounds on his
chest
he learns that Lisa and the other kids
at school were similarly attacked with
maintenance equipment in their dreams
while poor Martinez choked to death by
Willie's giant tongue during a desk nap
about Latin conjugation
Marge finally clues in the kids that
Willy is indeed trying to eliminate the
children of Springfield Elementary in
their dreams as revenge for the parents
who callously looked on when he burned
to death in a furnace mishap during a
budget meeting held on the spookiest day
of The Simpsons calendar
March the 13th
that's when Bart heads into his dreams
to force Willy into a fight to The
Bitter End leading to a terrifying scene
featuring Eerie green Skies spooky music
and Willy taking the forms of both a
monster tractor and a horrifying
combination of bagpipes and a giant
spider fortunately the frequently unsung
Maggie plays the hero saving the day by
plugging Willy's bagpipe exhaust pipe
with her pacifier
the story of selling one's soul to the
devil in exchange for worldly abundance
is an old one but the devil and Homer
Simpson a parody of the classic short
story in film The Devil in Daniel
Webster definitely puts its own spin on
things Homer is so desperate for a donut
that he offers to sell his soul for one
immediately Satan appears and in a big
twist it's the ultra Pious Ned Flanders
Homer signs the deal stipulating that
Satan gets his soul the moment he
finishes the donut and while he tries to
get out of it by leaving the last bite
untouched it's just too devilishly
delicious to resist
forbidden donut
hell's finest torturers try to dish out
one of the usual ironic punishments for
gluttony by forcing Homer to eat an
endless amount of donuts but for Homer
that's closer to Heaven eventually at
Lisa's behest Homer gets a trial in the
end it's Satan Flanders who gets the
ironic punishment as Homer's gluttony
saves his soul see on the back of his
wedding photo taken in a hospital
because he ate his entire wedding cake
before the wedding
there's a love note he wrote to Marge in
which he already pledged his undying
soul to her as a result Homer doesn't go
to hell but he does wind up with his own
head turned into a donut which she has a
tough time not eating
while many Treehouse of Horror segments
focus on the deadly sin of gluttony fly
versus fly concerns sloth in this
installment Homer buys two walk-in
matter Transporters at Professor Frank's
garage sale and uses them to be lazier
than ever he places the Transporters at
the top and bottom of stairs to avoid
five seconds of exercise then he goes
even further for first by using it to
get a beer without getting up from the
couch and then by using the machine as a
shortcut to the bathroom and not for his
whole body
things really go wrong when Bart sneaks
downstairs in the middle of the night to
experiment with the machines and
snowball 2 and Santa's Little Helper
head into one device emerging as a
two-headed cat dog and a two bottomed
monster respectively when Bart sees a
fly enter the transporter though he
proves that he's been reading too many
Comics by imagining himself transforming
into a muscular flyboy hybrid superhero
named Superfly
instead well it goes a little more like
it did with the family pets fly-headed
Bart loves his new life of feasting on
sugar and syrup and tries to permanently
replace both fly body Bart and Lisa
finally monster Bard eats little Bart
and gets shoved into a transporter
restoring BART to his regular State and
everything goes back to normal for the
family
of course
Homer does threaten to chop Bart up with
an ax because he dared to mess with his
dad's new toys without permission but
like we said back to normal for The
Simpsons
Springfield Elementary is a woefully
underfunded and poorly run school and
that's rarely Illustrated better than it
is in Nightmare cafeteria the detention
room is over packed and lunch lady Doris
has resorted to using grade F meat so
Principal Skinner comes up with a
monstrous solution that solves both
problems kill serve and eat the
misbehaving children the teachers are
nothing but amused when they taste their
first round of sloppy jimbos
German exchange student uter likes them
too but Skinner finds an arbitrary
reason to send him to detention simply
because the kid looks so tasty
sure enough the next day the school is
eating utterbraten and Skinner
accidentally admits the whole
cannibalism Gambit to Barton Lisa in
fact you you might even say we just ate
uder and he's in our stomachs right now
what's maybe even more horrifying is
that Marge refuses to help the kids
utilizing this as a teaching moment to
encourage them to stand up for
themselves and refuse to be eaten
despite groundskeeper Willie's ill-fated
attempts to intervene Skinner and lunch
lady Doris Corner the Simpson kids in
Milhouse and our young sitcom kids
experience a surprisingly grisly end
fortunately it was all just another bad
dream that Bart was having
unfortunately in the waking world
there's a fog going around that turns
people inside out and so this Treehouse
of Horror episode ends with a double
fake out and the skinless Simpson family
performing an incredibly gross musical
number that reveals Marge's hair has
muscles and veins classic Simpsons
like so many other Simpsons characters
Maggie is fully realized and comes with
her own unique set of quirks although
she can't walk more than a few steps
without falling and rarely speaks she is
one of the show's most beloved
characters here are just some of
Maggie's many Great Moments
one of the biggest television news
stories of 1995 parody the biggest
television news story of 1980. the sixth
season of The Simpsons ended on a
cliffhanger who shot Mr Burns
and the seventh season opener promised
to end months of speculation much like
the who shot Jr publicity stunt pulled
by The Primetime soap Dallas more than a
decade earlier it's assumed that Burns's
loyal assistant Smithers committed the
ACT
before descending into a boozy stupor
Smithers remembers feeling the need to
stop Burns and he later finds a
discharged pistol in his coat pocket
police only have two witnesses to the
crime Santa's Little Helper and baby
Maggie who reveal nothing in an
interrogation because well they can't
talk however that may be out of a desire
to not self-incriminate Mr Burns emerges
from a coma and identifies the shooter
as Maggie Simpson what happened was that
the awful old guy literally tried to
steal candy from a baby in this case it
was Maggie with a lollipop he fought her
for it and in the struggle his gun fell
out of its holster landed in Maggie's
hands and accidentally went off while
recovering in his hospital bed Burns
insists that Maggie be arrested however
Chief Wiggum knows better
yeah right pops no jury in the World's
Gonna convict a baby hmm maybe Texas
each member of the Simpson family has a
few distinguishing characteristics
for example Bart is a troublemaker Marge
is totally square and Maggie doesn't
speak that's partially a function of her
being a baby but a whole lot of comedy
can be mined from a character who's very
intelligent but stays silent however
Maggie does speak from time to time and
it's on such rare occasions that when it
does happen it's a certified TV event
with the big celebrity lending their
voice to the role the 1992 flashback
episode Lisa's first word features Lisa
as a newborn baby and it ends with Homer
putting Maggie to bed and quipping that
he hopes she never talks so that she'll
never talk back to him after he leaves
Maggie delivers the Magic Moment Daddy
foreign
Maggie's first word even more impressive
is that it was voiced by guest star
Elizabeth Taylor
then in the 1994 Treehouse of Horror
segment time and Punishment Homer
Kareem's through different realities
Landing in one where Maggie kills
groundskeeper Willie with an ax and
that's when she speaks again only this
time in the voice of James Earl Jones
this is indeed a disturbing universe
March finally cracks under the stress of
managing a household and raising three
kids with no help from her husband in
the 1992 episode Homer alone
necessitating a trip to Rancho relaxo
remember you can't spell relaxo without
relax
but Marge doesn't trust Homer to watch
the children for even a couple of days
and she shuttles Bart and Lisa off to
the sad apartment of Aunt Patty and
Selma however Maggie is smart enough to
know that's a bad scene and she refuses
to leave home despite Marge's
reservations Maggie stays with Homer she
was right to worry though because Homer
and Maggie are lost without her Maggie
is just a baby after all and she doesn't
understand why her beloved mother
suddenly disappeared albeit temporarily
so after Homer puts her to bed and
almost immediately trashes the house
with Barney she crawls out of her crib
out through the doggy door and into the
Springfield night in search of March on
the surface this is a plot about a baby
wandering the streets in the wee hours
but it's not too troubling because the
Simpsons is a family cartoon and Maggie
is surprisingly self-sufficient the
running gag for most of the episode is
that Springfield is full of things and
people that look like Marge and get
Maggie's hopes up including a shrub a
giant ice cream cone sign and a guy in a
beef eater hat working at a British
themed Quick Lube business
new job while you white don't touch me
as the youngest least mobile and almost
completely silent member of The Simpsons
family Maggie is rarely the center of a
main plot or subplot of an episode of
The Simpsons a show that despite being
animated and where time doesn't pass and
people don't age trades and realism
however Maggie gets her rare chance to
take center stage in a delightfully
surreal way during the 2015 episode
puffless closer informed to one of the
Simpson's themed theatrical shorts the
episode's secondary plot known as
Maggie's extraordinary Animal Adventure
is a self-explanatory self-contained
Lark in which Maggie makes friends with
a squirrel outside of her bedroom window
which is her entry into a secret world
of adorable Critters including an owl
opossum and duffman's pet parrot Maggie
takes charge and saves the day when
local Yoko Cletus traps the opossum so
he can cook him up and feed him to his
large family
I called us a possum you want to name it
before we eat it or after during
thanks to Maggie the friendly opossum is
freed after a full-on assault from the
Springfield animal community and it's
all done without anybody speaking a word
which is great news for Maggie and the
animals but it's a serious
disappointment for cletus's kids okay
well uh Possum's gone but you got
fingernails to chew on who knows what's
under them
the 1992 episode brother can you spare
two dimes staged a reunion between Homer
and his half-brother herb pal he was
left homeless and eating out of garbage
cans after Homer's failed car design
bankrupted his automobile company so how
does Maggie play into this narrative
well The Simpsons was barely into its
third season but it hit so big and
thoroughly that fans were already
clamoring to find out what was on the
mind of the baby of the family they got
their chance when Uncle Herb in an
attempt to restore himself to a wealthy
lifestyle invents a machine that
translates baby talk into plain English
he does it with the help of a two
thousand dollar investment from Homer
the almost always silent Maggie talks a
lot in this episode or at least she
babbles like a typical baby but thanks
to Herb's Brilliant Invention everyone
can finally understand the complexities
of Maggie's deepest thoughts
I have soiled myself how embarrassing
through a series of strange events and
misunderstandings a 1995 Simpsons
episode finds the county visiting home
Homer and Marge's home and deciding that
they're unfit parents
the kids are immediately placed in a
child welfare van and driven to a foster
home
yay hey Leo welcome to your new home
neglectri knows
while the episode is primarily a Bart
and Lisa Adventure focusing on the two
older Simpson kids as they miss their
parents and struggle against the creepy
Vibe of Flanders TV restricted
environment Maggie shines in a big way
throughout the story she's the reason
government agents ultimately decide to
reassign the Simpson kids as she's found
wearing a sign Bart originally placed on
Lisa's back reading I'm a stupid baby
and one of the big twists of the episode
is that Maggie really responds well to
her new lifestyle relishing in the
attention bestowed on her by the
Flanders at one point she even removes
her pacifier so she can Babble and call
Ned daddily doodly luckily the spell is
broken when she finally sees her mom
1992's A Streetcar Named Marge finds
Marge starring in a community theater's
musical version of the extremely dark
Tennessee Williams play A Streetcar
Named Desire but because Homer is such
an oafish lout she has to bring Maggie
along to rehearsals after Maggie
disrupts an intense scene between Marge
and Ed Flanders the place director
Llewellyn Sinclair forces Marge to drop
her off at his sister's daycare center
the Ein ran school for Tots inspired by
the philosophies of Rand Sinclair runs a
harsh school that promotes Stark
individualism and encourages children to
develop the bottle within which includes
confiscating all pacifiers that's a big
problem for pacifier addicted Maggie who
try sucking on her thumb crayons blocks
and anything else she can get her little
hands on eventually she attempts to
break into the locker where the
confiscated pacifiers are stored however
she gets caught in the act and thrown in
the Box a playpen equating solitary
confinement the centerpiece of the B
plot a grand parody of the Great Escape
soon commences Maggie brilliantly sneaks
into the daycare Center's vent system
and lowers herself into Miss Sinclair's
office with the string from a talking
Krusty the Clown doll she then grabs the
keys to the pacifier locker and uses a
makeshift zip line of her own devising
to access us the Forbidden treasure
despite the odds Maggie's plan works
even better than expected Maggie time to
go to the
a 1997 episode of The Simpsons my sister
my sitter looks into how funny it can be
when Maggie acts like an actual baby at
the beginning of the story Lisa proves
herself to be such a dependable and
mature kid that she becomes a successful
babysitter what do you say Helmer can
Lisa babysit for my kids please please
please I'll have to ask her
Homer and Marge even trust her to look
after Barton Maggie when they head off
to the fancy grand opening of
Springfield South Street squid Port
shopping district the idea of younger
Lisa in charge enrages Bart and he sets
out to make the night as bad as possible
for his babysitter refusing to eat
dinner and getting ice cream all over
himself that fake tantrum provokes a
real one in a stress-sensing Maggie and
Bart gives her ice cream to calm her
down one problem it's coffee ice cream
it jacks up Maggie into a twitching
grinning wide-eyed caffeine monster who
crawls on the shower curtain rod sprays
talcum powder on Lisa and runs off after
Bart knocks himself out Lisa has to
safely get the whole crew across town to
Dr Nick Riviera's sketchy clinic since
Maggie is so thoroughly and hilariously
agitated from the coffee Lisa puts her
in a cat carrier because she won't stop
sticking her fingers and passed out
Bart's face and as a grim finale she
intends to drown that poor cage baby
Maggie often seems to be off doing her
own thing and she's mentally and
physically separated from her older
verbal family members
sis in the many future set episodes of
The Simpsons in which Maggie is the only
one in the family who's both successful
and at peace with herself Homer seems to
die an awful lot Bart winds up a
destitute bar musician Lisa is president
but stuck in bad relationships all while
Maggie is off living the life she wants
to live and doing so as early as age
nine in future drama she isn't home on
BART and Lisa's prom night instead Marge
shows off a moving photo of Maggie
waving from a beach in Alaska she
doesn't speak a word as is the Simpson's
way with Maggie audiences also don't
hear a sound from 30-something Maggie in
holidays of Future Past by which point
she's become a world famous rock star
amusingly future Maggie is also the
eventual mother of a quiet baby who
looks exactly like her mom who's the
father
ah it doesn't matter
Disney welcomed The Simpsons to its
Disney plus service in 2020 with a short
titled play date with Destiny in this
completely dialogue free story Marge
takes Maggie to not responsible for
injuries Park where she meets a cute boy
that viewers learn is named Hudson at
least that's the name written on his
diaper it's love at first sight as they
hit the various Park attractions Maggie
and Hudson imagine they're engaged in
Grand romantic activities horsey spring
Riders becoming real horses a drinking
fountain doubles as champagne for two
and dining in Paris is in reality
sharing sand in the playground it all
ends during a game of peek-a-boo when
Maggie is surprised and heartbroken to
see Hudson's mom loading him into their
car after a good night Moon themed dream
in which everything turns into Hudson's
face Maggie preps for her next
playground date only to find to her
horror that Homer is on kid duty
unfortunately he takes her to a skate
park because they've got a taco truck
the next day Maggie doesn't take any
chances and wrestles troll of the car
away from Homer and drives them to not
responsible for injuries Park it's there
that she finally reunites with Hudson
for their first kiss well more like a
baby version of a first kiss
[Music]
The Simpsons has been around for so long
the series can be used to Mark the
passage of time in fact plenty of the
show's current viewers were born after
it debuted in 1989. if you're one of
these fans check out the most popular
episode from the year you were born
the most popular episode of The Simpsons
to air in 1989 was also the only one to
aired that year of course we're talking
about Simpsons roasting on an open fire
the very first full-length episode of
what is now the longest running show in
Prime Time history it's a classic
Simpsons tale about Homer bumbling
through life in order to make his family
happy and it's packed with relatable
moments hilarious disappointments and
cutting satirical humor early in the
story The Simpsons Christmas celebration
is put in serious Jeopardy when power
plant owner Mr Burns chooses fat
executive raises over holiday bonuses
for employees Homer doesn't tell Marge
the bad news because he thinks he can
dip into a big jar of money she has
stashed in her hair unfortunately Marge
ends up using this emergency fund on
laser Skin Surgery for Bart after he
gets a tattoo when her back is turned
forced to take on a second job for the
holidays Homer becomes a lackluster Mall
Santa he only ends up earning thirteen
dollars and decides to bet it all at the
dog track where he promptly loses
everything but fear not this first
Simpsons episode has a happy ending
after the race the losing dog that Homer
bet on jumps into his arms and Bart ass
if they can keep him he's a loser he's
pathetic he's
a Simpson
in 1990 The Simpsons was just about the
hottest thing on television and Bart
quickly became the breakout star so it's
not surprising that he served as the
centerpiece of the show's second season
premiere Bart gets an F which was also
the most popular episode of the Year
appropriately enough this installment
forces BART to reckon with his immature
decisions in Bad Boy ways after faking
his way through a book report on
Treasure Island which he didn't bother
to read and cheating off of Milhouse on
a test the school psychiatrist tells
Homer and Marge that it would be best
for BART to repeat the fourth grade Dead
Set against it Bart actually tries to
improve his marks and gets class brain
Martin to tutor him in exchange for
popularity lessons after forcing himself
to study art defies everyone's
expectations and does well enough on a
history test to pass though he just
barely scores a d-minus still it was
enough to earn his test a coveted place
on the fridge right next to one of
Lisa's Mini Eggs
viewers can pick up Clues from early
episodes of The Simpsons that Homer and
Marge are in their late 30s and met at
Springfield High School the 1991
flashback episode the way we was
provides a lot more detail by depicting
the story of Homer and Marge's first
days as a couple the idea of a Simpsons
episode set in the 70s featuring a young
Homer in March was irresistible and the
way we was ended up as the most watched
episode of 1991. back in 1974 High
School senior Homer lands in detention
yet again for smoking in the Boys Room
studious Marge winds up there for the
first time because she burned a bra at a
feminist rally when she walks into
detention it's love at first sight for
Homer and he immediately wants to ask
her to the prom to get close to March he
hires her as his French tutor despite
not actually taking that class after an
undeniable chemistry develops between
them and she accepts his prom invite he
lets it slip that he lied about French
class feeling betrayed Marge goes to the
prom with Hansen nerd Artie ziff instead
standing up a heartbroken Homer at the
end of an awful night for both of them
Marge picks up Homer off the side of the
road and they share their first fate
ceiling kiss
while Lisa's first word prominently
features Lisa as a baby the real reason
this is the most viewed episode of 1992
is that it was a huge milestone in the
life of Maggie in the run-up to this
episode's airing Fox heavily hyped the
fact that Hollywood Legend and Academy
Award winner Elizabeth Taylor would
guest star as the voice of Mac towards
the beginning of the story The Simpsons
move into their home on Evergreen
Terrace but that's just the first of
many changes in store for the family
Bart is also forced to contend with a
creepy clown bed that Homer made because
he needs to give up his crib for the
newly born Lisa the new addition gets so
much of his parents attention that Bart
starts acting out and threatens to run
away but he stopped in his tracks when
Lisa says her first word Bart at the end
of the episode The Action returns to the
present where Homer puts Maggie to bed
telling her he's in no rush for her to
speak because he doesn't want her to
talk back after he leaves the room
Maggie delivers the moment everyone was
waiting for
Daddy
it's no secret that Homer is a man of
Simple Pleasures especially when it
comes to alcohol but in duffless the
most popular episode of 1993 Homer pays
the price for his Endless Love of beer
as The Story begins Homer sneaks out of
work to take the duff brewery tour with
Barney naturally they both have a few
samples rendering Barney physically
unable to Drive Homer who didn't indulge
as much as Barney gets behind the wheel
and is immediately busted by Chief
wiggle charged with drunk driving Homer
is stripped of his license and forced to
attend Alcoholics Anonymous meetings my
name is Homer and I'm just here because
the court made me come Homer with our
help you'll never touch a beer again
[Music]
Marge worried about Homer's addictive
behaviors thinks giving up beer for a
month might be a good idea for him he
reluctantly agrees and though it's
extremely difficult he eventually
succeeds in the process he saves a
hundred dollars and loses so much weight
that he no longer sweats while eating at
the end of the month Homer even resists
his urge to down a few beers at the bar
instead he goes on a romantic bike ride
with Marge let's just hope he didn't end
up taking her to Moe's
The Simpson's annual Halloween specials
are a TV tradition that still endures to
this day in 1994 the phenomenon reached
critical mass as Treehouse of Horror 5
ranked as the most viewed episode of the
year the episode starts with a parody of
the horror classic The Shining where Mr
Burns hires The Simpsons to be the
winter caretakers of his remote Mountain
Lodge but he makes sure to get rid of
all the beer and TV sets sending Homer
into a murderous rage then in time and
Punishment Homer tries to fix the
family's toaster and accidentally turns
it into a time travel device after going
back way too far and squishing a
prehistoric insect Homer zaps his way
through various bizarre timelines
created by his actions including a Ned
Flanders rule dystopia the episode
finishes out with nightmare cafeteria in
this segment Principal Skinner helps
lunch lady Doris figure out new ways to
serve the kids on a budget are you
saying you killed Jimbo processed his
carcass and served him for lunch
while the owner of Springfield's nuclear
power plant Mr Burns is famously cruel
the 1995 episode who shot Mr Burns part
1 demonstrates just how low the wicked
Tycoon is willing to sink after oil is
discovered under Springfield Elementary
School bringing much needed funds to the
poorly resourced institution Burns
steals the lucrative crude with his
slant drilling company not only does he
destroy large parts of the town in the
process including the Springfield
retirement castle and most Tavern he
creates a monopoly on energy forcing
everyone in the region to get their
power from Burns's sources by the end of
the episode Burns has been shot by an
unknown assailant and is barely clinging
to life while sprawled out on a sundial
of course this is only part one of the
Simpson's most famous Cliffhanger which
left the world wondering who shot Mr
Burns well I couldn't possibly solve
this mystery can you
yeah I'll give it a shot two years after
earning some of its biggest Halloween
ratings ever another Simpsons Fright
Fest Treehouse of Horror 7 scared up
enough viewers to rank as the top
episode of 1996. some of the interest in
this episode might have been influenced
by that Year's presidential race which
was between Bill Clinton and Bob Dole
The Simpsons always a satirical show
made fun of both candidates in his
Halloween Special by having recurring
Alien Invaders Kang and codels abducted
two men take over their bodies and run
for president in their place as the
aliens point out the United States has a
two-party system so Americans have to
vote for one of them and then wind up
enslaved in the Anthology episode's
other segments Lisa's tooth in a Petri
dish experiment leads to a rapidly
evolving Society where she is worshiped
and in the final story The Family
confronts Hugo Bart's monstrous twin
brother who's been kept chained up in
The Simpsons attic
Fox was responsible for more than a few
hits that dominated pop culture in the
1990s but only one dared Crossover with
the Simpsons The X-Files bringing FBI
agents Fox Mulder and Dana Scully to The
Simpsons was at its core a publicity
stunt and it worked like gangbusters the
Springfield files was the most popular
episode of 1997. one night a very drunk
Homer walks home from most Tavern and
stumbles into the woods where he comes
face to face with something completely
unexplainable a wispy glowing big-eyed
creature resembling popular depictions
of aliens news of the encounter reaches
Mulder and Scully and they journey to
Springfield to investigate the
mysterious sighting eventually it's not
the X-Files Duo that cracks the case but
Lisa she forces Smithers to come forward
and explain that the presumed alien is
actually the elderly and decrepit Mr
Burns it turns out that his weekly life
preserving Medical Treatments leave him
so confused and disoriented that he
wanders around the woods the glow
assembly be a side effect from working
around nuclear power for so long
in Bart Carney the best performing
episode of 1998 The Simpsons explored
the sketchy world of traveling carnivals
when the carnival comes to Springfield
and the family decides to check it out
Bart gets himself into trouble almost
immediately he hijacks a car that the
carnival claims once belonged to Adolf
Hitler and smashes it into a tree to pay
for the damages bar and Homer become
carnies under the tutelage of father-son
Carney Duo Cooter and Spud the Simpson
guys learn all about fixing games and
bribing police although Homer fails to
properly pay off Chief Wiggum despite
his many hints this gets Cooter and
Spud's game shut down which is also
where they live taking pity on them
Homer invites them to stay with the
family he soon learns that he shouldn't
have trusted the two carnies before long
they temporarily assume ownership of the
house and won't let the Simpsons back in
you can't do this to me what about the
Kearney code
[Laughter]
in maximum Homer Drive the most watched
episode of 1999 Homer is intrigued by a
promotional stunt at a steakhouse
whoever can eat a 16 pound steak with
all the trimmings gets it for free he
then accepts a challenge from a
long-haul truck driver named red Barclay
who bets Homer that he can finish the
huge meal before he does red is the
first to polish off his steak but in the
process he dies of what Dr Hibbett
diagnoses as beef poisoning Homer taking
all the wrong lessons from this
experience decides there's only one
thing to Do complete Red's last delivery
with Bart by his side of course he does
this without knowing how to drive a big
rig or understanding the culture of the
road I Want You To Blow Your Horn oh
hey it's a little punk it's a little
surprising that it took until the
Simpsons 12th season for trickster BART
to become a professional con artist fans
were apparently eager to experience this
foregone conclusion firsthand as the
great money Caper was the top episode of
2000 at the beginning of the story a
Sturgeon Falls from a space station and
crashes into the Simpson's car after
that unexpected event Bart and Homer
decide to busk as a magic act so they
can earn enough money to fix the family
car this game doesn't go according to
plan and the duo only earns 60 cents
Homer quickly loses his patience with
Bart and drives away without him when
passerby take pity on the boy he starts
raking in the cash without having to do
anything after Bart takes a taxi home
and buys himself a steak dinner both
Simpson guys realize that they could
just grip people to earn money no
busking skills required naturally it all
goes bad and eventually Homer and Bart
get caught by an FBI agent but even that
is a ruse the agent is in fact an actor
hired by Marge to teach Homer and barter
lesson the 2001 episode Homer attempts
to explain why the Simpson's dad has
such a unique personality to put it
kindly fans were so eager to learn how
he got to be so Homer like that they
made it the most watched episode of the
year after Homer gets a job as a medical
test subject doctors find a crayon Lodge
in his brain it turns out that when
Homer was a child he shoved 16 of them
up his nose he thought that he had
sneezed them all out but one stubborn
crayon stuck around for decades after
Houma has it surgically removed his
unencumbered brain finally works
correctly in fact Homer suddenly becomes
intelligent cultured and able to relate
to brilliant Lisa for once they even go
to the library together however after a
few ups and downs Homer realizes that he
was much happier when he was less
intelligent luckily Moe was more than
willing to hammer the crayon back into
his brain and restore Homer's previous
level of intelligence
extended warranty how can I lose perfect
large March from 2002 is absolutely
packed with silly psych acts which
helped it become the most popular
episode of the year for example when
Lisa wins a bet with Homer and gets to
choose their daddy-daughter day activity
she has them build houses for domiciles
for the destitute they work alongside
ex-presidents Bill Clinton George Bush
and Jimmy Carter who engage in three
stooges-esque physical comedy in violent
slapstick later at the work site Homer
demonstrates to a couple women how March
birth bark only for her to drive by and
think that he is flirtatiously flexing
his muscles for them worried that Homer
is losing his passion for her Marge
decides to get liposuction unfortunately
the surgeons mix up their patients and
provide the episode with its Central
plot line and its most obvious site Gap
what on Earth have you done my my
guppies became bazangas in 2003's I'm
spelling as fast as I can two big events
simultaneously passed through the
Greater Springfield area a championship
spelling competition and a Mania for
crusty Burgers rib Rich of course Homer
gets addicted to the rib witch a
sandwich whose meat sauce is couched in
secrecy he joins a group of rib heads
who travel around to different Krusty
Burger locations according to the
sandwiches rolled out release schedule
Homer's new adventure in gluttony comes
to an abrupt end when Krusty announces
that the rib witch will be discontinued
as the animal from which it's derived
has suddenly gone extinct meanwhile Lisa
quickly Rises through the ranks of
competitive spelling and a surprise
twist writer George Plumpton asks Lisa
to throw the finals to a more popular
remarketable competitor named Alex if
she goes along with the plan she'll
receive a full college scholarship in a
George Plimpton Hot Plate Lisa of course
sticks to her High morals and announces
during the competition that she was
asked to to throw the contest she then
defiantly continues to compete sadly she
then misspells her word and knocks
herself out of the finals still her
family is incredibly proud of Lisa and
her second place finish you're the
number one speller in this car or in
dead car or in that car or you don't
look at that guy building fighting
robots is an ongoing Pastime for
thousands of people but in the early
2000s the pursuit enjoyed a mainstream
moment with shows like BattleBots The
Simpsons tapped into this Fad in 2004
and it paid off the robot themed story I
do bot was the most popular episode of
the year after Homa does a terrible job
of assembling Bart's new bicycle he
decides to make it up to him by
constructing a battlebot to compete on
the TV show robot Rumble Homer's not the
most talented engineer however and
resorts to crafting a glorified robot
costume he places himself inside then
goes on television and suffers through
many violent beatdowns until Bart
finally discovers what his dad has been
up to but this doesn't stop Homer he
continues to fight until the truth
finally pops out
robot giving birth to
in 2005 Fox had the rights to the Super
Bowl and gave the Simpsons the honor of
airing a special episode right after the
big game that installment Homer and
Ned's Hail Mary pass seems like it was
custom made to retain as many sports
fans as possible and it clearly worked
since it was the year's most watched
show when a video of Homer doing a
victory dance after winning a carnival
game goes viral several prominent
athletes hire him to choreograph their
own celebratory dances LeBron James Yao
Ming Michelle Kwan Warren Sapp and Tom
Brady all put in a request and are all
voiced by their real world selves
Homer's dances grow into such a cultural
phenomenon that he wins a plum gig
organizing the Super Bowl halftime show
he recruits Ned Flanders to help him out
seeing as how his Pious neighbor has
been making a name for himself by
producing violent biblical films for the
big halftime show Homer and Ned recreate
the story of Noah's Ark for millions of
football loving fans of course the
reaction of the viewing public was
pretty predictable All Over America
today viewers were outraged by the Super
Bowl Halftime Show's blatant display of
religion and decency
there are few evil characters who
Delight in their villainy more than
Springfield's resident billionaire
industrialist Charles Montgomery Burns
and today we're looking at the worst
things that Mr Burns has ever done in
the long history of The Simpsons in one
of his most diabolical and high-profile
acts of bond level villainy Mr Burns
once constructed a giant disc designed
to cast the entire town of Springfield
in Shadow for 24 hours per day in effect
the plan was to force Springfield to
rely on electricity supplied by his
nuclear power plant rather than natural
sunlight the ACT proved to be the
Catalyst for the infamous who shot Mr
Burns two-part mystery that saw the
entire town outraged by Burns for plenty
of other reasons earlier in the episode
The Town turned on him after he tapped
an oil well beneath Springfield
Elementary causing the school to lose
funding and the town to be plagued by
environmental disaster the sun blocking
plan however was so vile that even
Smithers broke Rank and had to walk away
from his life with Burns I I don't want
any part of this project it's
unconscionably fiendish I was not suffer
your insubordination and after
announcing his nefarious plan to the
entire town who are now armed to the
teeth Burns might have thought he'd
cross the threshold from infamy to
invincibility but a swift shot from an
unlikely townsperson put an end to that
perception still Burns blocking the sun
remains among his most high-profile acts
of villainy it showed that he was okay
with the entire town wanting him dead if
it meant a few more bucks in his wallet
when The Simpsons returned for its
seventh season the finale of the who
shot Mr Burns two-parter revealed that
it wasn't the grand villainous plan to
block out Springfield's son or even any
of his other considerable acts of greed
that got him shot instead it wasn't even
more Craven and Petty act Mr Burns
straight up tried to take candy from a
baby after appearing to conquer the sun
burns felt even more invincible and
entitled to do whatever he pleased in
his case that meant stealing a lollipop
from Maggie Simpson unfortunately for
him he was unaware that his pistol was
precariously placed in its holster and
in the old man struggle with the baby
the gun went off in to his chest giving
him some much needed comeuppance in the
episode The Trouble with trillions it's
revealed that after World War II
President Harry Truman minted a one
trillion dollar bill in an effort to
reconstruct post-war Europe the U.S
government then tasked a spry young Mr
Burns with flying the money to Europe
surprise surprise it never arrived
obviously stealing an incomprehensible
amount of money meant to help people
after one of the most devastating pieces
of human history alone has got to be one
of Mr Burns worst acts but wait there's
more after Homer helps discover that
burns still has the bill the FBI burst
in to arrest him but Burns manages to
escape by fleeing the country the second
part of his Escape Plan buying a tiny
little Caribbean island he found on a
map unfortunately that Island happens to
be Cuba which some will note is kinda
spoken for when it comes to land
agreements armed with a trillion dollars
in cash though Burns attempts to just
purchase the country from its president
Fidel Castro Castro proves to be a
little too cunning for burns though he
just asked to see the bill and then
pretends it was never handed to him with
that burns returns to the states
defeated but like most super rich
criminals he never actually faces any
consequences
2001 Greyhounds from the sixth season of
The Simpsons is responsible for one of
the better toe tappers in the show's
long musical history it's also one of
Burns's most evil acts to date
especially if you're an animal lover he
one of our puppies
[Music]
admit it's catchy when the Simpson
family dog Santa's Little Helper gets a
little frisky with another Greyhound the
family finds themselves The Proud yet
overwhelmed owners of 25 puppies
although they make a valiant effort to
care for the dogs they're forced to sell
them as they debate letting an oddly
interested Burns take the whole litter
the devious Tycoon steals them when
their backs are turned fortunately Bart
and Lisa track them down at Burns Manor
and hear him singing his plans to make
the dogs into a tuxedo it turns out he's
been making clothes from adorable
animals for years that's bad enough to
Merit inclusion on a list of his worst
acts but doing in two dozen puppies for
the sake of fashion is a new level of
evil fortunately Bart and Lisa intervene
before he can do his Grim tailoring job
but Burns holds the two kids at gunpoint
in order to stop them in the end Burns
is convinced that he shouldn't off the
dogs and vows to never wear the fur of
another animal as long as they can do an
amusing trick sorry Gophers this is a
unique inclusion on the list because it
marks a rare occasion in which burns
doesn't Revel in his villainy in instead
his bad behavior merely comes from a
deeply misguided place after a series of
bad Investments causes Burns to lose his
vast Fortune the episode The Old Man and
the Lisa sees him forced to live the
life of an average Joe even shacking up
with Smithers for a brief period however
his quest to find fulfillment as an
impoverished elderly person is
short-lived as his life quickly spirals
out of control and lands him in the
retirement Castle when Lisa Simpson
comes around on a crusade to increase
Springfield's recycling Burns decides to
mend his previously greedy Ways by
attempting to give back it seems like
things are going well as Lisa's desire
to help the environment meshes with
Burns's business Acumen however upon the
opening of the little Lisa recycling
plant Burns reveals that he strung
together hundreds of plastic six-pack
holders to sweep the sea clean of both
waste and marine life in a horrific but
very well animated shot we see hundreds
of animals being dragged from the ocean
and turned into a meat slurry that burns
then sells and best of all it's made
made from 100 recycled animals Lisa is
obviously horrified much to the
confusion of burns who genuinely
believes he merely took recycling to the
next level although this is by far one
of Burns's worst acts it's scary to
think that this kind of Carnage is what
happens when he goes with his best
intentions instead of his worst
The Simpsons has been around for a very
long time and while every episode brings
with it new jokes some gags have been
recurring again and again for years from
our geography to embarrassing photos
here are the best long-running jokes on
The Simpsons
The Simpsons is a satirical comedy which
means that to strike as broadly as
possible it has to be set in the most
average seeming Place imaginable so
writers came up with Springfield a
mediocre Town that's also full of
goofballs and Weirdos so as not to
impose any Regional characteristics on
the mid-sized City and keep it as down
the middle and relatable as possible the
state where Springfield sits has
aggressively never been revealed all
viewers really know is that its capital
city is literally named capital city and
that the governor is named Mary Bailey
diligent Simpsons fans have looked for
contextual clues for years trying to
pinpoint Springfield's exact location
but they'll likely never find it it's
physically and geographically impossible
for Springfield to be a real place
information about its Locale is
purposefully contradictory and it's one
of the show's best prolonged gags in the
Behind the Music Parody episode behind
the laughter Springfield's location as
given as both Northern Kentucky and
Southern Missouri in The Simpsons movie
Ned Flanders says the town is nestled
between such far-flung States as Ohio
Maine and Nevada
in many episodes of The Simpsons Homer
mindlessly watches television and comes
across an infomercial invariably hosted
by aging washed up B-movie actor Troy
McClure McClure usually introduces
himself by saying I'm Troy McClure you
probably remember me from such films as
the Revenge of Abe Lincoln and the
wackiest covered wagon in the west you
then lists a couple of terrible sounding
old movies from his apparently vast
resume of Forgotten projects among his
dozens of credits we've got the boat
jacking of super ship 79 dial M for
murderousness here comes the Coast Guard
they came to burgle Carnegie Hall and
Gladys The Groovy mule Troy voiced by
big voice Saturday Night Live cast
member Bill Hartman got a lot of Hosting
work in The Simpsons universe as he also
introduced hotel information videos
telethons and tv specials while listing
his corresponding past credits his work
in educational films is particularly
hilarious with titles such as earwigs
you lead paint delicious but deadly and
2-3 equals negative fun the running gag
comes full circle when the Simpson
family actually meets Troy McClure and
mentions the films they remember him
from
Homer Simpson is a man of Simple
Pleasures but all the beer donuts and
bad TV are offset by a strange fixation
on goals he never has the drive to
achieve Marge you're standing in the way
of my Boyhood dream of managing a
beautiful country singer
the result Homer has earnestly stated
several times that a given aspiration is
his Boyhood or lifelong dream among
those gulls there's his desire to manage
a country music singer to be a monorail
conductor own the Dallas Cowboys be an
inventor like Thomas Edison live in the
woods and get rid of Bart whenever Homer
brings up another steadfast dream Marge
almost always points out that he
recently fulfilled his dream like eating
the world's biggest Hoagie running out
on the field during a baseball game or
appearing on the televised Talent
contest The Gong Show playing a huge
harmonica with Barney while both were
inside a giant pair of overalls
in recent Seasons Herman Herman
proprietor of Herman's military antiques
hasn't appeared all that often on The
Simpsons in the early days of The
Simpsons however Herman was a
predominant side character a Springfield
townie on par with the likes of Kent
Brockman or Helen Lovejoy and similar to
those characters in their handful of
defining traits Herman had his whole
thing too Herman knows a lot about
military history and strategy and he's
also rather paranoid physically it's
quite noticeable that Herman is
completely missing his right arm viewers
might presume he lost it in a long ago
combat Skirmish that's not necessarily
the case writers made a dark and
ghoulish running joke out of just how
Herman became separated from his
appendage in the 1990 episode Bart the
general Herman claims that he stuck it
out of the window of a moving bus and a
passing truck tore it off years later in
the episode to Cur with love it's shown
that Herman lost it while trying to hail
a ride and it was ripped off by Chief
Wiggum driving an animal control vehicle
as it was in real life there was a
hotline for everything on The Simpsons
in the 90s and just like in the real
world the hotlines in the series would
have such high call volumes that they
put callers on hold and make them wait
for a while allowing time to pass with
some soft rock hold music The Simpsons
mocked this phenomenon by making the
weight music as savagely funny and on
the nose as possible for example when
Homer feels disconnected from Bart he
calls the national fatherhood Institute
for help and while on hold they play
Harry Chapin's gut-wrenching absentee
dad song Cats in the Cradle in another
episode when Marge leaves baby Maggie in
Homer's care she runs away and so Homer
owns a missing child hotline and quickly
tears up when the whole music is players
Baby Come Back
characters on The Simpsons coin a lot of
words and one of the best is retirony a
clever construction from the usually
less than sharp Chief Wiggum that can be
used to identify an especially durable
running joke from The Simpsons itself
its combination of retire and irony and
Wiggum tells a financial planner in the
2000 episode Homer versus dignity that
he doesn't have a plan for the future
because retire any will ensure he's shot
and killed three days before he leaves
the police force but what if you don't
get shot what a terrible thing to say
The Simpsons first use of the retire any
concept is a direct jab at action movie
cliches in a 1991 episode Homer watches
a McBain movie in which the title
character is just about retired partner
is brutally shot by a Hitman all while
the poor guy is holding a photo of his
new boat the live forever retiring was
subsequently taken to absurd places
Homer smashes a news camera hidden in a
hat which had one day left until
retirement while searching for Homer a
police dog one day from retirement
smells the man's Underpants and runs
away and then Marge accidentally frees a
group of prison inmates who Chief Wiggum
notes were quote one day away from being
completely rehabilitated
the Triangular Flags known as Penance
seem like an old-fashioned form of
showing fandom since Mr Burns was seen
holding a beat Harvard pennant after
attending a game in the 1996 episode
Burns Baby Burns but the pennant gag is
also a reliable staple for Homer Simpson
for years Homer seemed to always have at
the ready a professionally made pennant
for every occasion no matter how minor
inappropriate or private The Experience
he had an XFL pennant to watch the
ill-fated football league's launch at
home on his couch one reading mid-season
to greet the arrival of replacement
television shows a girth one to
complement his fat Pride t-shirt and
even when reading Justice that he held
Aloft from the sitting area of a
courtroom
initially conceived as a guide for Homer
Simpson to play against Lenny Leonard
was both a work friend and drinking
buddy to the main character of The
Simpsons a fellow mid-level employee of
the Springfield nuclear power plant and
a frequent customer of Moe's Tavern and
over the decades that The Simpsons has
been on TV Lenny's character and
backstory has grown deeper for example
viewers learned that he has serious eye
health issues and very bad luck relating
to those eye health issues this all gave
Lenny one of the Simpson's grossest and
funniest running gags some unknown
injury left Lenny with a fragile peeper
and yet it's frequently attacked by the
one ultra-specific thing his doctor has
said to keep out of there Homer throws a
dish of pudding at Lenny but he's not
supposed to get pudding in that eye he's
wrestled to the ground on top of the
jigsaw puzzle even though he's not
supposed to get jigs in his eye other
times Lenny and his poor eye are just in
the wrong place the wrong time like when
he takes off his eye patch for the
allotted five minutes a day and fish
guts get inside of it or then there's
the time to that Homer pranks him with
the old snakes in a can bit sending a
spring right into his cornea
the Springfield nuclear power plant is a
big place and it's one of the town's
biggest employers it's absolutely
logical that the aloof cynical and cruel
man who owns and runs the place see
Montgomery Burns wouldn't be on a first
name basis with all of his underlings
but it's hard to believe that he
wouldn't remember Homer Simpson from one
day to the next after all the safety
inspector from sector 7g has worked at
the Springfield nuclear power plant for
many years and they've often interacted
off the clock even in ways bordering on
intimacy or friendship for example Homer
and burns were on the same bowling team
Homer acted as Burns romantic wingman
and Homer once served as Burns prank
monkey this is to say nothing of his
attempts to woo Marge steal away Grandpa
Simpson's girlfriend or his enduring
rivalry with Grandpa Simpson himself
that's why the running gag of Mr Burns
completely forgetting Homer Simpson is
so funny the character is so mean and
self-serving that he can't even find a
few brain cells to remember a man with
whom he's shared multiple experiences
whenever Homer comes up in conversation
Mr Burns has to ask Smithers who he is
and this disregard is even held up as
Homer's motive for trying to kill Mr
Burns
Springfield's favorite bartender most is
lack of Moe's Tavern is a deeply
unpleasant guy and Homer Simpson is one
of his few friends MOA spent a lot of
time around Homer's family and has a
particular fondness for the Simpson
children and yet he never seems to
recognize Bart Simpson's distinctive
voice during one of his numerous prank
phone calls to Moe's place of business
that only makes the running joke of Bart
calling up the bar even funnier with the
Simpson boy asking to speak with a
patron whose name is an obvious and
slightly risque pun and most slowly
realizing he's been made the fool flying
into a rage is all over there oh Oliver
clothes off
Bart isn't much of a student but he
really puts in the effort when coming up
with big names for his prank calls among
the more memorable there's alcoholic Lee
kibam Amanda hug and kiss and Theo
problem the joke really sails when Mo
reacts perfectly asking to hold bar if
the person with that name is there only
to completely lose it when he realizes
that he said he has a Bo problem
Springfield isn't all that big a place
and Homer Simpson does a lot of dumb
things that creates the unique situation
in which he winds up featured on the
Channel 6 news with Kent Brockman
reporting on his latest bone-headed or
accidental Shenanigans in providing the
audience with background info on the
subject of the story Kent will pull up a
file photo the station already has on
hand of Homer Simpson it changes with
the episode and it can only hilariously
hint at just what stupid activity Homer
was engaged in when the photo was
snapped there's at least a whole
season's worth of Simpsons episodes that
could tell the Stories Behind These
extraordinarily damning and embarrassing
pictures such as an angry pantsless
Homer shaking his fist at a zoo ape
Homer with his tongue stuck to a pull
and Homer apparently trying to set some
kind of world record with more than a
hundred cigarettes stuffed into his
gaping mouth
[Music]